Dude, Tom is lucky that he got out before he's wearing full-on
makeup on stream. Okay. >> I would never meow. I would
never meow for anyone merch.
Uh-huh.
Uh-huh. Uh-huh.
I think we're going to do the lyrics stuff. Okay. You guys know
who Lyrics is? You guys remember lyrics? Liam Donovan. Liam Donovan
Music. This is actually pretty funny stuff. Okay, you guys know
who this is, right? Lyrics.
Lyrics. Liam Donovan music. This guy was a commentary YouTuber.
He was uh pretty tightlyworked in with a lot of the standard
commentary people. Nicholas Dioro, Turkey Tom,
um all the smaller commentary channels as well. Lyrics. Why did
Why did it say trans lyrics? Well, because Lyric decided to show
up to his most recent stream and do a whole video with him wearing
like fanboy makeup. Okay.
That's particularly disgusting because he has, of course, evviscerated
Boaxs. He has mocked the [__] out of trans people
broadly. Okay.
He was Quan's best friend. Don't let him forget. Um, I don't
think so. I'm pretty sure not.
I I don't know. I I feel like he wasn't. I mean, I talked to
Queen a lot. I've never heard him say a nice thing about lyrics
like ever in his entire life. Yeah. I think this is what Stylo
says, right? I've literally never heard Quan say a nice thing
about lyrics in my entire life. Can somebody find me a clip of
him saying something nice about
Lovers turn sour. Okay. I've literally never heard him say a
good thing about lyrics. Although, to be fair, in in my defense,
I don't think I've ever heard Cleman say a nice thing about essentially
anybody who he's seen more than twice except maybe Red Bar.
I think it's like red bar and then red bar and then I I can't
think of like another human being. Yeah. Anyway, so this guy,
he decided to do this like crazy stream. All right. Or this crazy
video on Taylor
>> and there's just a whole backtory in the commentary
community. Oh, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait. I actually
So, there it is. Okay, there it is. This is the video. I do need
a little more I do need a little bit more setup as well. a year
ago he would but his co-orker nicities that lyrics was stupid
but stood on business and would always talk [__]
out which is what Queen values
maybe
I think he stopped talking [__] out >> welcome
back to the channel >> so if you guys are unaware
lyrics also for a long period that he was a commentary YouTuber
had his entire chat trying to groom him into transitioning into
being like a fanboy into being trans. They would constantly post
pictures of him in dresses in like with like more feminine fe
facial features. Like he had a group of like wine moms who fetishized
and like probably degenerate old dudes who fetishized the idea
of him being trans. And I think so when he transitioned over
cuz this when he transitioned over to being a music YouTuber,
which is his new channel. Okay. I think he basically closed down.
He doesn't have his old channel. Like he doesn't run his old
channel anymore. He used to do a commentary channel and now he
does like music reviews. He basically saw Brad taste of music
and was like, "Oh, that seems like a really good thing. It's
a wine mom thing." Ah, some wine mom things. Some some wine moms
do that. Gear for profit like Finster. So, I think in my mind
this is this is going to be the conclusion, but I'll say it now
cuz when I looked at this is obviously like where I got to. I
think Lex believes that he can try to make the Finster money
and pull up before he hits the ground. Okay. Basically,
there are people who are willing to pay to put you into a nose
dive towards
towards being fully trans. Okay? The people who are willing to
put you into that to pay to put you into that. And Lar believes
that he can pull up. Lar believes that he can get control of
the plane and pull up. And I don't know if that's true. Okay.
I don't know if that's true. I think he's going to try to cash
in from these
But hold on, there's more. There's
one more thing on the side here which is very interesting. Okay.
And there's a couple people who a couple people have looked into
this. They never pull up. I don't think he'll pull up either,
but there's his girlfriend. So, do you guys know lyrics and lyrics
girlfriend? Do you know who this girl
>> You guys know who this girl is. There's a funny backstory
to this girl. Okay. I believe I I'm not wrong. Right.
There's a very funny backstory to this girl.
This is Turkey Tom's ex. So, if you guys don't know the backstory,
Yes. Yes. Canadian caller. Yes. YOU GUYS DON'T KNOW THE BACKSTORY.
All right. Basically, Tom was dating this girl and then I think
they had some issues. I don't know what they had for issues,
but she started with lyrics while they were like not fully broken
up. You know how like you get out of a relationship and there's
this period where it's like I'm not sure if we're going to get
back into it. I think she started with lyrics like
And there's this joke about how Tom carved her name into his
chest. This is who he was living with in Canada, I believe. Okay.
And there's this joke about Tom getting by lyrics. Getting cut
by lyrics. And then basically, I think not once, but maybe twice,
maybe maybe even three times. While her and her and Tom get back
together eventually. Okay. Her and Tom Oh, Tom started doing
his nails. Wait, did he did he he didn't paint his nails, did
he? When he was with this girl?
No, he didn't paint his nails when he was with this girl, did
he? No.
No. Oh, no. Oh,
no. So,
okay. So, yeah, apparently, cuz listen,
there's some evidence as we get into this that she might have
pushed him into doing this. Okay, she might have pushed lyrics
into doing this. All
So, okay. So, anyway, her and Tom did get back together. I believe
they got back together. And then eventually, Lar is on stream.
He's covering some drama on Twitter and he leaks his DMs and
shows that he's talking to this girl
And then either before or after that, I'm not sure in the timeline
there, her and Tom are broken up and her and Larry get together
again.
So, it's like this whole thing and I'm I'm feeling like dude,
I feel like Turkey Tom, it's actually 2026 is going to be the
year of Turkey Tom. He's going to come back. He's going to have
a generational run. I'm not even joking. I know a lot of people
don't like Turkey Tom, but he managed to escape. Okay, he managed
to escape and now he's watching the guy who like pseudo cooked
him, if not actually him. And he's watching that guy turn into
a woman. Okay, Turkey slowly turning into the Roman legot. Okay,
Larly turning into the Greek
like fem slave. Okay, this only goes one way. This only there's
only one thing that happens in 2026. Okay. It's the year of Turkey
Tom. First, not his first experience with gay, but his first
experience with being the top. Okay. >> Of performative
male music. >> Oh, hold on, hold on, hold on. I think I
was just showing the girlfriend for a second with this one. That's
all I was doing. Okay.
But his his first video, so he did this with his [clears throat]
>> Apparently, she painted Tom's nails. Check Discord gen
chat. Hold on.
What do we got in Discord gen chat?
Something happened in Discord gen chat. What is this?
Yo yo yo yo. What the dude? Yeah. So So
Tom saved himself. Okay. She It was all her. It was all her.
It was all her. Dude, Tom is lucky that he got out before he's
wearing full-on makeup on stream. Okay. He barely got out in
time to hit the gym. That's That must be what sent Turkey Tom
on his spiral down into like masculinity
like like masculinity maxing. Okay. He met up with this girl.
She was slowly trying to feminize him. And when he escaped, he
immediately was like, "Okay, I have to I'm hitting the gym. I'm
I'm like I'm learning like I'm going to read Marcus Aurelius.
I'm going to read meditations. Okay. I'm uh I'm I'm masculinity
maxing cuz that I came so close. He felt how close he came."
Okay. This changer is grooming young white men. She appears to
be. All right. She does appear to be. Well, do I have this this
title correctly? Oh, I don't have this title correct. Hold on.
Hold on. Real quick. Title change. Real quick. Title change.
All right. So, Jesus Christ.
The title could be accurate. The title could be accurate. Stoicism
sucks dick. Okay. All right.
Is Tom a fanboy, too? Well, he was. This is very feminine.
This is incredibly feminine right here. I think Tom hit the gym
just to like get away from this aesthetic. Now, I don't know.
Is it Can we guys Can we all agree that it's not really that
masculine to hit the gym because you felt like your girl controlled
you? Like your girl was getting you to to like, you know, blow
out your hair and paint your nails and wear these like weird
goofy outfits with like the the stripes and the emo t-shirts.
I don't know, man. It's a slip knot shirt. Maybe not emo.
I think I think he's hitting the gym.
because he doesn't want to be he doesn't want to be who she made
him. Okay.
Yeah, sure. It's not emo. Yeah. Yeah. I corrected myself before
I even finished the commentary. But
okay, that's that's just setting up who Lyrics is. Who Lar's
girlfriend is. Okay. Do we have Wait, do I have the clip where
he's talking about trans people? Is that this one? What is this
one? But what if he got owned by this little [__]
in a dress aka
>> the [__] are you guys sending me? Come on,
man. Get this away from me. >> That's him. That's him reacting
to his community, by the way, who constantly fetishized him is
transitioning. That's him reacting to his community, fetishizing
his transition
like six months ago, 12 months ago. All right. So, that's how
far we've come. He's been How long has this guy been in Canada
living with this girl for? Can someone tell me
how long we got? How long is on the clock?
6 months.
So, I saw I saw a tweet with it. Somebody get me the clock on
how long it took for him to go from being disgusted by this idea.
This is the This is the clip of him being disgusted by this idea.
Okay. To being like, "Oh, you know what? Actually, I do like
makeup and I do like looking cute."
Oh, it's just me experimenting. It's just it's just an experiment,
guys. [__] [__] away from you. >> Hold
on. Hello. Reban Ruben donated $3. We are jolly good. >> Oh,
thank you, Reuben. Appreciate it, >> This guy's a little
like Jaden. He's just a little like a little fem. He wears skirts
to school. He diapers. He's basically got a big He cries all
day about he wishes he was a girl. Like, bro, just get surgery.
Just get a
>> That's by the way, that's lyrics again. That's him saying
these things.
Just like that. Sucking, bro. Little Suck my Actually, no. Suck
my That'll be your first to suck. >> But what if he got
bruh bruh?
Terrifying stuff. Okay. Absolutely. Dude,
dude,
it's it's pretty dire. Okay. It's pretty dire.
Hold on. I I'll be real. I I took a couple tweets from >> Welcome
back to the channel. A lot of changes. A lot of changes are going
on here. a lot of huge things.
But anyways, everyone,
a new Boax Challenger approaches.
Okay, it'll be far less It'll be far less distressing than the
Boax situation. Let's just be real. It won't be quite as disturbing.
It won't It just won't. It just won't.
Boax was the worst person who could have been trans. Okay, it
was like the worst case scenario.
I'm just saying it. All right, I'm just saying it.
That was like that was horrifying. That was a horrifying situation
for everybody
There's a lot of tweets. A lot of people in commentary were tweeting
about this. Okay. Men used to go to to war with a picture like
this in their wallets.
Hold on. I can't find the explicit picture, but like uh look
to the skies
when you're on estrogen.
was the joke Turkey Tom's girlfriend made with him. Okay. That
he was transitioning into her.
It's all about It's all about this Kai person. Okay. It's all
It's all about this Kai person right now. Hold on. I Oh, I also
got told that I could basically just go to Deeperama's Twitter
and like scroll like just free scroll Deeperama's Twitter cuz
apparently this is
good. Okay. Apparently he was very involved in this. Hold on.
Hold on. Hold on. Give me a second. Me go to Deeper's Twitter
and
from here. Okay, let's check it out. Uh, scientists have finally
created something that could get me to sit through disc by Magdalina
Bay.
Don't Okay, new Liam Donov Donovan video posts are now a pants
off affair. Happy days.
Jesus Christ, dude.
Liam Donovan is like if Kurt Cobain was brave enough to transition
instead of taking the coward's path.
cuz she my Liam la Liam. Okay,
dude. Liam understands that you don't have to worry about your
music scaring the hoes if you become the hoe. What was the shim
bit?
Oh, this is a What is this one? This one is
pinned pinned comment from him for anyone wondering. No, I'm
not trans. just doing things to my appearance that I think look
cool. It begins. Thank you all for watching your continued support.
A lot of a lot more content coming that I'm really looking forward
to. So, thanks again for any wondering anyone wondering. No,
I'm not trans. Just doing things to my appearance that I think
look cool. Nothing deeper. Lol.
That's Is that not exactly what Vinster said? And then exactly
what Pyroynical said? How long can we get a countdown on how
long it took for Pyrocynical to go No, I just think it's like
kind of cool to look feminine to him posting like a full-on lingerie
photo shoot at some point. Can we get the What was the time span
there? Was that like a year? Are we like a tminus one year from
the lyrics
like lingerie photo shoot? Pyroynical is a woman now. No, Pyroynical
was posting like he posted some [__] in like lingerie.
It's up dude. It's incredibly up. Vincer does NSFW now. I know.
Wait, did what did Pyro go trans? Did Pyrocynical not I thought
Pyroynical like openly went and was doing if not trans stuff
then like fanboys? I don't even know how you differentiate. Uh
Finster said that and their pay kept donating at the end of the
time period so they had to keep up the bit. Yeah, I think that's
what's going on with lyrics to tell you the truth. He apparently
launched this in partnership. Okay. or in in direct
coordination with himself. Not coordination really, but he launched
a Twitch channel with this as well.
dude, he launched a Twitch channel with it was like, "Oh, guys,
also just go follow the Twitch." Also, my my my new stream, my
fanboy stream. Oh, well, we're also launching a Twitch right
now.
Incredible. Incredible. Incredible
But hold on, there's more. There's more tweets. There's way more
tweets. Okay, hold on. Do we Did I show the I don't know if I
showed the
You showed the salvo yet. There's this one. Hold on. Where's
the other salvo tweet? I've got it here somewhere. I grabbed
the second salvo tweet. >> I think it comes before this
one before I lose this. Okay.
dude, hold on. Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait. I Oh, I didn't
grab the other one. Okay, well, it's fine. This is the better
one anyway.
Full statement on Lar's Christmas doll full glam look. Is he
queer baiting? >> Listen, I got to call it out. Isn't technically
what Lar is doing? Wearing full-blown Christmas doll blush and
full coverage B. >> Oh, hold on, hold on, hold on, wait,
wait, wait, wait, wait, wait. I think he had a statement before
this. Okay, just a little meme. Give you a flavor of where this
is going. This is just a phase for this young man. Unfortunately,
that's the most embarrassing, humiliating part. way more normal
if he was gay or trans. A homoerotic phase. Blame his girlfriend.
>> Can you possibly, but yeah. Okay. I don't want to get
too into it. Okay. I don't want to get too woke. >> Okay.
I don't want to I don't want to spoil too much of this stream
either. You show the picture again for those of us who just woke
up. Me. Can I show the picture of Larry? This guy and his like
fanboy makeup. I want to see him in his fanboy makeup. Don't
worry, we're going to go to a stream. >> How much It's
just like realistically, man. How much sympathy can you possibly
have for someone who actively like spent his life going like
trying to take away and advocating for basic human rights to
not go to gay people? Like what? What?
That's it? That's nothing. No, it's not nothing. It's not nothing.
And the reason it's not nothing is because of like the content
this guy did on Boaxs. It's the Oh, that's about Charlie Kirk.
Oh, interesting. That's funny, dude. Hold on. I saw Auggie tweet
a Charlie Kirk clip as well. This guy's like constantly on trans
people, constantly on like LGBT,
bro. It's It's pretty
pretty wild. Really to the AI tweet. Well, I'm guessing we're
going to get all of this in the stream. Maybe I Maybe I do the
stream next. Maybe we got to go to the stream. Okay, maybe that's
what we got to do. We got to hit up that stream right now.
Okay,
we'll do this thing first, though. Just a little wearing fullblown
Christmas doll blush and full coverage BB creams and eyeliner.
Isn't him doing that que baiting? And isn't that a big faux paw
big no no?
Like lyrics.
We're going to have to see you do something a little more gay
now. Like you could wear the makeup and do all that,
but until we see you like kiss a boy or a man or like do something
a little more gay, I'm going to look at that as you're just in
a phase
peer pressured by
your girlfriend as a this is you're either you're either a Okay,
either you are a weak man who's been pressured by your girlfriend
into dressing like a woman or this is a expression. Okay. And
I need to see you suck a dick.
Post the video. Make the only fans right now or you're a totally
for your girlfriend who's willing to put on makeup. Okay. Them
them's the brakes, buddy. All right. Suck the or admit you're
not a man. Suck the or admit you're a only two ways to only two
ways this can go. >> A young man, this is what happens.
Young men get a cute girlfriend. They're in love. They start
believing everything. You can believe your girlfriend, but you
have to make some discernments that sometimes they're not fully
right on things. You should not be getting into full makeup and
full Christmas doll on the shelf glam.
If you are just a straight man, that part is weird to me. That
part is weird. But if you're not just a straight man,
hey man, it's 2025.
Wear that makeup, wear that eyeliner,
show us. Do you know what I mean?
>> I want to see that eyeliner running now. I want to see
that eyeliner streaming down your face. Okay, really put some
effort into it, you little
Thank you, Salvo. We all We were all thinking it, Salvo. I thank
you for saying it. Okay, thank you. >> Now you're queer
baiting and that's
Someone linked me the pyroynical pictures. Jesus Christ. Also,
it's every single time. I'm never doing this again. I'm never
doing this again. I'm never
I'm never doing this again. I'm never I'm never going to do it
again. Oh, hold on. I forgot something very important. Okay,
that's Pyroynical and that's like the photo shoot he did. I'm
not even going to scroll through all of the ones on stream, but
that's the Pyroynical photo shoot he did. Okay, wild.
Wild.
Every single one of these guys is like, I'll stop taking the
money before they get me on hormones. I They'll do it. Okay.
Apparently this money for for posing as a fem, there's something
about the genetics and the physioamtomy of feminine men that
like they will they will just slide into that role and every
single one of them convinces themselves, no, I'll stop. I'll
stop taking the money before I get on the hormones. And then
every single time they get on the hormones, okay, it's every
without fail, they're just like, oh, I can do it. I can pull
up. I can pull up. Okay, we put ourselves into a nose dive.
If you start suggesting other commentary YouTubers who you want
to transition, I'm going to say that you either you have two
options. You can sub at Oiler to the Patreon and then feel free
to make those comments, okay? You pay me money to say those degenerate
things in my chat or [__] off. One of the two, okay?
One of the two. Pick one.
Give me money if you want to make those weird comments. Or [__]
off. Okay. Don't talk about who you who you fantasize about transitioning.
It's gross. Weird. Weird.
Okay. Very strange behavior. Very odd stuff. Hold on. Hold on.
People are linking things.
uh. Okay. I don't know what this guy's saying. Never mind. Okay.
Uh hold on. Where are we going? We're looking at the stream.
Oh, let's look at the Alec Gunter clip. The Alec Gunter flashback
real quick. Okay, real quick. >> How old is this guy? He
looks underage. He looks like he's like 14. Okay, you take it
up the ass like when nobody's looking and you >> Dude,
this is wild from Alec Gunter. Everybody called him out on this
to go. It's a little crazy to go. You look 14. You look like
you take it up the ass. Wait, what? Huh? >> How old is
this guy? He looks underage. He looks like he's like 14. Okay,
you take it up the ass like when nobody's looking and you you
deny it at every point when nobody even brought it up. You're
like, "What do you mean in the app?" And they're like, "I I asked
you what you wanted for dinner." Okay. Well, just so it's clear,
I did not get in the app. Like, that that's the look that you're
giving off. >> How's Mrs.
>> We all thought Alec Guner was making the We all thought
he was totally schizophrenic. Turns out this guy was like tapped
in somehow. He was tapped in. He was a prophet. The people heard
him and they were like, "You're a weirdo."
The real solution or the real answer was, "He's a weirdo and
he's right." He's a weirdo and he's right. How is it both >> tip?
Think about that one. >> What? Dog, where's your husband?
Dog, you're 14. Shut up. Go back to school. Like he he looks
like he's 14. Some 16year-olds look like adults. The problem
with is not finding somebody who is underage attractive. Okay.
If you find somebody who happens to be underage, who's like 16
or 17,
that's not a big deal. It is not a big deal. If I go up to somebody,
some chick that I think is attractive, okay, and say, "Hey, you
know, you look great. Why don't I take you to dinner sometime,
okay, and then she >> really stop being about lyrics entirely?"
Didn't it >> turns around and says, "I'm 17. I'm here with
my mom or whatever." And she's in the other store. You know,
if this guy >> What is he? Bro, this this clip actually
Hold on. This actually broke me out of the lyrics thing. Wait,
what? Wait,
dude. I feel like it got so specific. Uh, it's not weird that
like she her mom's she's 17 and her mom's in the other store.
Wait, what? >> Who already looks like he would fit makeup
very well. Makeup and a dress. I I'm I'm serious. Like he look
he would look good with makeup and a dress. Not >> Oh [__]
>> Maybe you should try it. >> You know, now I know
that you are a virgin. I get that. But now that you know that,
maybe next time you can avoid making this dumbass comment that
only a 14-year-old would make. Bro,
Al Alex Gund is just that guy, I guess. I don't know. Hey, maybe
you should try it. Maybe try wearing makeup. Okay, makeup in
a dress.
Lyrics heard the makeup part and he he's engaged in part one.
I'm It's really unfortunate that he It's basically a guarantee
that part two is coming. >> All right. Not only do you
look like one, you also think like one. >> What? But I
wanted to end off this video on one good note with one final
statement from Chipster himself. >> When you got a you
got a I what? This guy doesn't clean. Is that your problem? You
got big ass blue balls, man. Go go whack one off. I promise you'll
feel better. Maybe do it to uh somebody your ass. Thanks for
watching. If you enjoyed the video, please be [laughter] sure
to hit the like button. Subscribe if you want to >> Dude,
this this this shirt gives him powers that you can't even imagine.
Okay. The shirt gives him powers that you couldn't possibly fathom.
He can forecast a trans person from years away. All right. You
You guys don't know it. Okay,
this is all this is all it was. Everybody who watches commentary
generally just doesn't really like trans people or is super,
you know, homophobic in some way. This guy This guy knew
He had the sight, okay? He had the He had the inverse Shinagami
eyes, okay? He had the inverse Shinagami eyes, not the ones that
tell you who the anti-LGBTQ
people are. He had the ones that tell you who they are, okay?
Inverse Shinigami eyes. Let's go.
Let's go.
Oh my god,
dude. [clears throat] Nothing deeper. Lol. Nobody believe you,
bro. No. Ain't nobody believe you, bro.
My god.
Liam Tom so hard that he is now also becoming the [__]
he stole from him. Okay. I don't know. I don't know. I don't
know if there's anything else. Is there anything else?
Lyrics when he drinks a bottle uh a bottle of water for the first
time in a year and breaks free from his girlfriend's fluoridization
bottle.
fertization mind control.
Oh no. Okay. Is he Is he not wrong, dude? Sorry. Is he not done
yet? He's not done yet. Jesus, there's more tweets.
Demonic women feminizing their sensitive young boyfriends is
like when a feral homeless person smears all over their tent
so nobody else touches it.
H. Isn't that the truth?
My god. Okay.
All right. We're finally finally finally ready for the actual
onream portion. Hold on, hold on, hold on, hold on, hold
Yeah, so he he had a live stream and
what is this? Okay, so he had a live stream. Let's check it out.
>> Let's check out some parts of the live stream. Stream
starting soon,
bro. His his whole chat, his whole subreddit constantly
talked about transitioning him, t constantly drew him as a girl.
It's so crazy that he leaned into it. >> Who would have
thought? He's scared to turn on the cam.
>> What's your problem, man? I'm good.
>> Oh no, >> I'm good. >> Oh no. Oh no. This
reminds me of Do you remember the game developer who was trans
and didn't want to turn the camera on and was like talking to
their chat and they're like, "I'm ready to face reveal." And
then they How up is it for that person that they're actually
trans and they look like totally like I would
[__]
I would have if I were trans and I look like that person. I have
crippling dysphoria. I'd probably Dude, that would be rough.
Okay. You're trans. You looked like L. That's like not even a
It's like not even a problem.
I would No, I'm telling you L looks far more like a girl than
that other trans person. Do you not
I'm telling you, I would I would have like the one person looked
like they were they looked totally masculine. They had like nothing
going on. Larax at least looks like a girl. Like he looks feminine.
He has soft feminine features.
That's by the way, you guys are like, you're going, "Hey, wait,
bro. It's I'm sorry, but that's literally what everybody agrees
on here. That's literally the joke in all of these places." No,
he doesn't. Yes, he does. It's been the joke forever that he
has like soft feminine features. has always been the joke. Timer.
I don't even know how much time we got. Oh, time's out. Well,
we'll get through as much of this as we can. What is up?
Hello. Hello. Welcome all.
Okay, the chat kind of looks congested here, but hello.
How's everybody doing? [snorts] How >> If Emir fans squint,
they know they see Emmy. Oh boy. >> How is everybody doing?
It's good to see >> That's [__] up, dude. That's
really >> good to see you. It's good to see you. We got
great things.
We got great things.
Hello. Hello. We got great things. A third of our screen is text
now. Okay. Well, okay. I don't know what else to do about that
because I want to have it big.
I want to have it big. I want to So, this is what everybody does
now to get away with um you have to do this for Twitch, right?
That's why I see a ton of people doing this so they don't get
banned. You can't mix chats. So, you just show Twitch chat and
the other chat at the same time. I think >> habits.
Okay, that's probably better. Is that better? Like in between
right there? That's >> significantly worse, bro. >> Is
that good? Is that better? >> Fboy. Fboy. Fanboy. >> Super
hyp hyper realistic. Fix your
>> What do you mean fix my eyes? Oh yeah. By the way, I
also have to say like at the start of this, >> there's
no way they did their own eyeliner though. That is so good.
Yeah. Well, that's kind of the theory take and is you missed
the whole thing at the beginning of this where this guy is dating
Turkey Tom's ex-girlfriend who slowly is going to transition
him. Okay. Who's been slowly transitioning him over time? Yikes.
Um, for Q submissions, I still have the Q submissions from like
a couple day a day and a half ago because
my stream like
crashed or whatever. So, we have to do those. So, uh, Q is closed
for now.
Uh, dating again. Again, dating again. Wait, as in there? I I
feel like Yes. He didn't he move to Somebody told me he moved
to Canada. Did he move to Canada to be with her? Or are you saying
that her and Turkey Tom are dating? No, that can't be the case.
That's these two. These two are dating. He literally did the
video. I just watched the video with him and him and Kai
second time. Well, were they dating the first time or were was
was he just Kai while Kai and Turkey Tom were broken up? I put
out a video prompt of Yeah, this girl right here. Bro, I didn't
even realize how close this girl seems who Oh, this girl
I didn't even realize,
but
actually looks like I'm Alex's girlfriend. I'm Alex's ex. Have
people pointed this out that they they look very similar? She's
like not
There's like a real overlap. There's a real similarity there
between her and the like I'm Alex's ex. I can't remember her her
name. Alice Hezeline. Alice Hez.
>> Do we have uh Okay, I can't I can't scroll down far
enough on her, but it's like the same person. It's crazy. Performative
male music. Oh, whoops. Wrong one. Wrong one. Back to the stream.
Anyway, that's who that's who's doing his makeup. >> Q's
closed for now, but um yeah. Um don't worry. I am going to do
those though for all the people who donated on the 4th. Uh yeah,
cuz it's 6:00 now,
But hello. How is everybody doing? We look at the Look at how
good I'm just I'm having not addressing the elephant in the room.
What's the elephant, man? Speed ran joining Twitch and became
a fanboy. Okay, man. Thank you. [snorts]
this is great. I'm just so pleased about this. I'm so happy.
I liter I You don't know. You actually guys have known. You've
known how difficult it's been for me to get this started. Okay.
[snorts] For me [laughter]
Oh, I see. So, he wants to pretend that it was difficult to get
the Twitch channel started, right? That's what he wants to pretend.
But we all know what it was difficult to get started. Yeah, I
think we all we all understand. We get it, bro. We >> This
dual streaming stuff is no joke.
>> It's a total joke. It took me 30 seconds to set up after
I've been streaming for like a week. It's a total joke. What
are you talking about? Dual streaming stuff is no joke. So, now
that we got it, this is great.
Put fanboy in the category. Thank you. I appreciate the Chase.
I appreciate the al the algorithm advice. I'll be looking into
that. Okay.
Um,
but there we go. Look at this. Maybe make Twitch chat smaller.
There's less chatters here. Yeah. So um for
this right here for like the normal stream here let me just put
this as perspective
for the normal stream
this is what it will look like you know there could be slight
adjustments but this is like you know basically the concept is
that YouTube is like around like 65%
to 70% and then the Twitch since it's not as big right now it's
going to be like you know 20 to 30%. So,
you know, we could uh we could adjust that to see like you as
a fanboy is going to bring a whole new audience. Okay. I guess
it's uh I guess I I guess it's we address the elephant. The makeup
really makes your eyes pop. It actually looks great. Wow. Wow.
Thank you. Cuz do you know what every cafe is saying? Every cafe
is saying evil things. He says I look hyper realistic.
What does that mean?
Bro, you were getting mad at being called a fanboy. Like,
man, what a boring stream. Okay, I can't tell if you talk about
mine or his. Talk about mine, there's plenty of other streams.
Talk about his, there's plenty other streams. Seems like something
you don't really have to complain about. >> Like two weeks
ago, what happened?
>> You're already You're already on a different stream.
You're good. Hey, I just I I didn't say anything, man. I said,
listen, plenty of different streams. It's like not a big deal.
There's lots of people who are boring. He's trying to come out.
Listen, this guy is having a hard time speaking because he's
sharing an extremely personal thing that he was very ashamed
of for a very long time with his chat. Okay. Desire to dress
like a woman. And yeah, he's like, listen, there's a lot of flags.
And now I need to I need to Oh, yeah. Yeah. Yeah. That's definitely
He's got the trans fingernails. Okay. He's got the trans fingernails.
Do you think he knew, by the way? Do you guys think that Larry
knew that his girlfriend did his his fingernails as like the
trans flag? Do we Do we pick this up? You're missing a moment
with this pause. Hold on. Rewind. Hold on.
>> What does that mean?
>> Bro, you were getting mad at being called a fanboy like
two weeks ago. What >> I still am mad. I >> Bro,
bro, he went to flip his hair.
He just had to control himself. He went to flip his hair, you
know. Oh, he went to flip his hair.
Oh my goodness. >> What happened? I still >> He was
He was about to flip his hair out of his eyes. Oh my god. >> I
am mad. I still am mad at it. What do you When did I >> Did
you see him add the baritone back to his voice? I still am mad.
I still am mad. I still am mad with all of you. I'm mad. I'm
very mad. Why would you Why would you imply I'm not mad that
you called me a fanboy? >> Stop being mad. Okay, >> hold
on. Hold on. Hold on. Oh, wait. Did I Wait. Have I left this
on low the whole time? Oh god, has my voice been like that? Wait,
has my voice been like crazy forever and you guys have never
said anything? Oh,
that's [__] up. Wait, how did did this sound that
crazy? Was that like a big
It's scratchy now. Oh, no. Never mind. Never mind. Never mind.
Was this what I was going to do? Oh, this is the direction I
This was the direction I was going to go in, right?
Was this the one to do the bassy bassy base? Is this the bassy
bassy bass?
>> No. Oh, well then I don't know how voice meter works,
so I'm just going to reset it. [laughter] >> Boy, like
two weeks ago, what happened? I still am mad. I still am mad
at it. What do you When did I stop being mad? Okay. When did
I stop getting angry at that? When did I stop? That has not stopped,
man. That is still going to happen. No, but uh
yeah. Okay. But look at this. Who is in Who is in the stream?
Who is in the chat? This is so great.
Dude, you're mad at you gota call the fanboy. No, I'm not. No,
I'm not.
So, anyway, look at this. Who's in the stream right now? Who's
in the stream? Who's in the stream right now? Oh my god. Oh my
god. Oh my god. >> Um, no. But, uh, yeah. Okay. But look
at this. Who is in Who is in the stream? Who is in the chat?
This is so great.
This is so great. This is so good. I'm so happy. I'm so pleased
about this. How many people do we have on uh Twitch, by the way?
How many Can we see this real quick? Okay. Oh, everyone. everyone.
I need people to follow too immediately. Is the quality good
or is that just my Wi-Fi? So, we're at 180 followers, guys. We
need huge things. Okay.
Your skin looks clearer. Yeah, that's the insane thing about
makeup. Okay. It's the biggest uh cheat code in the world. Okay.
I still not addressing I'll talk about it in a second. Okay.
But first and foremost, Oh, that have you thought about doing
a channel where it's just you being a fanboy? They don't even
care about your music, dude.
This is
ah this is some this some very
this is some sinister. Okay, this is very sinister. >> Most
you have to you have to follow the Twitch everybody. Um follow
the Twitch. We're doing great things.
Liam Dunovan music enterprises are expanding. Okay. Expanding
in ways that you could not possibly
talk projecting.
Projecting what?
This doesn't make any sense.
This this is actually sinister. I'm telling you that this guy's
being groomed by his audience. It's like s it's there is something
very sinister happening here.
And it's like it's so it's soed up. Not because it's just that
sinister. It was really sinister when it happened to Finster.
Okay. It's really sinister because people went, "Hey, you're
just like Finster. You're going to do the same thing Finster
did. You're going to do that exact same thing." And then he's
like, "No, I'm not. That's so gross. That's so gross that you
guys say that [__] It's so gross that you try to
make me do this." And then he does it anyway.
He spends months being like, "It's so gross that you guys say
this. So gross that you guys joke about me being a fanboy. It's
so gross. It's so g." And then he just shows up to stream wearing
makeup one day. How old is he? I don't know. 24 to 26 somewhere
in there. 22 to 26. 4C. So go follow it right there. I need I
need to see at least 200 followers by the end of this. We got
26 people in here right now. Twitch chat. Hello. Look at Look
at these emotes. I'm getting furry emotes. This is the greatest.
See, this is why we really need That's a signal. That's a signal.
They are very cute. >> They are very cute. Samplified the
wolf. Samplified the wolf says they are very cute with a little
cute furry emote.
Yep. Yep. These are the people that would show up for the stream.
Yep. Yep.
Yep. Yep. Yep. Yep. Yep. Yep. Yep. Yep. Yep. Yep. Yep. Yep. Yep.
Yep. Yep. We're screaming since Chud Logic. [laughter]
No, Tre, you totally You totally want to text all these trans
people. You totally want to suck with all these trans people,
Chud. It's totally normal. Hey, it's co, buddy. It's co. It's
fine. Hey, it's 2024. Sorry. No, it's not. Would have been what,
2020? 2021. Hey, it's 2021, Chud. You could totally you could
totally with a bunch of trans women. It's fine. You got it, buddy.
>> Okay. Um, but there we go. Liam, what's the Discord?
Please link. Uh well, it's it's in my channel bio for the exclusivity
one, but I'm going to start a new discord as you know, generally
I'm trying to uh
you know, outreach my content more and more. I'm going to make
like a community discord that isn't just exclusive, but then
I'll have an exclusive one as well. But don't worry, that that
will be happening. [snorts] >> But um did he just totally
nuke his channel or his old one, his old Discord? Because he
had an old Discord. He had an old channel and I think he got
rid of them because he didn't like that people knew who he was
from like his previous content. Also, I will not rule out the
theory. So, if you guys don't remember, some people who liked
his new music, I don't know why he's talking like that. Some
people who didn't like his new music or his new music channel.
Sorry, I just started. I I read a message and I answered and
then I totally [__] up. Let me take another run at
this. Some people from his new channel didn't like his old content.
some specifically some of the like anti-LGBT,
some of the anti-trans stuff he did, like some of the jokes he
made, they really didn't like his old channel. Okay. And is this
not the perfect defense against all of those criticisms? He thinks
he's found a model here where he can retire. I can do music content.
I love doing music content. I can retire on this content. I can
do it forever. Okay. Is it not the perfect defense against all
old content to just transition?
Just take the hormones, bro.
in this economy. You telling me a couple people here wouldn't
take the hormones to to have financial security? That's that's
the decision he's making. Okay. Lyrics is going, "Okay, my old
content can't hurt me if I just transition." All
[laughter] He Brad should have trimmed out. I'm telling you,
wait. How can I possibly be held not responsible for all of my
actions? I know. I'll become a woman. [laughter] Oh, sorry. That
was too That was a little too easy. That was low hanging fruit.
My bad. My bad. >> You changed your mind. Yeah, because
you know what I was worried about is like people being like creepy
in like the audience, and I don't really want um creepy people
in the audience.
>> Oh, dude.
yeah, people won't get creepy about this. They definitely won't.
>> My gosh, the donations are so small. I got to adjust
that. B in comparison to the chat messages. Uh thanks for the
5B. It's lowkey me off how much better eyeliner looks on you
than it does on me. Thank you. Okay, I appreciate that. >> Um,
but >> Uh-huh. Uh-huh. >> No, what I was going to
say is
[snorts] >> we are getting furry emotes. This is so great.
Yeah, man. Yeah, I need more emotes. Yeah, we could do custom
emotes, too. It's just this is like the first stream ever that
it's working. Look at this. These Lucarios. See, this is the
only thing like that the Twitch is good for. Okay. Okay. [laughter]
No, Twitch should be good. Twitch should be good. But that the
emotes are cool because I have like barely
>> Lucario is a furry dog whistle. Lucario is a furry dog
whistle. Lucario is a furry dog whistle. Okay. Unironically,
uncomplicated just very obvious. Lucar did I say Lucario? Lucario.
Lucario. I don't know if I said Lucario, but
Furry. Furry coded. Absolutely. All furries want to [__]
Lucario. It's very >> Any of those on uh YouTube. Colton,
thanks for the two. What the hell happened when I was gone? That's
what a lot of people are saying. I You weren't gone for long,
man.
It's just, you know, what do you what do you what do you want?
What do you want from me? What do you want me to say? >> Everybody's
Everybody's saying
>> Spruce Willis, thank you for the gifted sub. Thank you
guys for the subs. Really appreciate it. Thank you. Thank you.
Thank you. Thank you for the time. Hold on, dude. What the What
the hell happened while I was gone? Somebody asked. What the
hell happened while I was gone? Uh, some stuff happened while
you were gone. Okay, hold on. Hold on. Let me see if I can find
it.
>> I put out time. I tried to time it. I tried to time
it. I don't know if I could time it quite so well, but we
>> Me. Address. Add address me. Address me. Like the elephant
in the room. What do you want from me? Okay.
What do you want? You look like Princess Diana. I did hear that.
It's the hair, right? It's the hair. There. There is something
to explain, >> bro. Stalling. Okay. I guess that was everything
I need to say. I guess I guess I can uh you know in general talk
>> anything. Released a video released a video today uh
which I recorded this morning similarly
okay that's so weird to say man. See that's the so it wasn't
so it wasn't
Hold on. He recorded the video this morning shooting the stream
I assume one day ago. Hold on. We got a time stamp on the start
of this stream.
So, he's saying he spent the whole day in that makeup. What were
you doing that makeup, bro? [__] Were you doing that
make you wearing that makeup all day?
I mean, I That's a part of That's a part of the grooming, by
the way. That's a part of the grooming. Do the makeup in the
morning for him. And then she's like, "What are you just going
to take it off and then we have to reapply it for the stream?"
No, leave it on. Leave it on. It's fine. Just leave it on, man.
Just leave it on. >> The problem you're That's so weird.
Okay. SmackDagle. Long time. Long time no see. But Liam, you're
actually morphing into Caitlyn. It's what' you say? That's insane.
That's so That's so weird. That's so weird to say. Smaggle. You
got to You got to cut that out. I love your nail polish. We Yes,
we all go defend boy. Liam.
Um Liam, do you have cat ears stashed away? Put on fur ears.
Put on fur ears. Did your girlfriend do your makeup? Yeah, he's
not going to get any weird comments at all. Yeah, no weird comments
are coming. Oh, I also just realized we got to go look at the
uh the comments that he liked on his first video real quick.
Just as an aside about not getting weird comments. We love supporting
small fanboy creators. Liked by lyrics. I don't want weird comments,
guys. I don't want weird comments at all. Fboy Donovan. Liked
by lyrics. Wow. No likes. No likes. No likes. No likes. Those
wings are beautiful. Love the self-expression era, Liam. Oh,
you're so pretty. Liked by lyrics. Hold on. We have any more
liked by lyrics here? We might not. I think I saw at least three
and then I'm not sure if there are other ones. No, it doesn't
appear to be. Doesn't appear to be, but
Okay. Still,
how [__] crazy is that? That's nuts. These aren't
that bad.
I don't think you understand how badly this guy blew up over
the trans stuff. I don't think he like was running his channel
on anti-boax content. He's the guy who Boax had like one of his
final meltdowns with cuz Bob like called him to try to get him
to like
not talk [__] about him and then Bobax recorded the
the video or recorded the call and tried to publish the call
and he wasn't even like weird on the call. But did Boax him over?
Not really. But he had a whole bunch
of anti-boax comment uh commentary. Okay.
They 100% got blackmail on each other. They don't. But did you
already go over those clips? No, I didn't go over those clips.
I'm just talking about it. >> If you want to be around
these parts, you know, that's strike one. No, but uh let me see.
Okay, I guess what am I even supposed to do? What am I supposed
to respond to? I guess we we'll do this. Overall, we have a fun
stream coming tonight. It's going to be late, but um but I did
want to make sure to stream because I was uh the last stream
like glitched out and I was supposed to stream that day for the
schedule. So, don't worry. The schedule is not got we're not
getting rid of the schedule. It's just finally I figured out
all of like the issues
um
with Twitch and YouTube. So, just say you're coming out. Who
cares? Okay. Coming out is what? What do What do you mean, man?
Coming out. I'm not I'm not coming out is anything. I'm not I'm
not I'm not transgender, you know? Nothing wrong with it, but
you know what I mean. I'm not uh I'm not I'm not transgender.
Blue Diamond, thanks for the one. Yoliam, I sent you a very important
message on Discord. An urgent message you should take a look
at. Okay. Should I Should I see?
okay. That's a lot, man.
Wait. Okay.
Huh? Okay,
dude. Were you We're Dude, we're fully for it. We're fully for
it. >> If you want to chop your thing off, you're so brave.
Do that.
Dude, we're fully for it. If you want to chop your thing off,
you're so brave, dudette. Uhhuh. Uh, thank you very much for
the five gifted anonymous. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. Thank
you. And extoay, thank you for the 15 months. Appreciate it,
guys. After stream blue,
okay, that's cool.
That's cool. Well, it's just like I can I say it?
Can Can I Can I say it? It was just like the the Reddit guy just
quit. Okay, that's that's okay.
Can you send me a long message here? I'll take a look at that
later.
Um, don't worry, man. That's okay. >> What's up, B? How's
it going? >> I appreciate it.
Well, I'll take a look. I I'll take a look at that later. Sorry.
Um, but
all right. What? Okay, so here we go.
Let me call in you little cutie pie. My goodness. Coming out
as a girl
He's actually gatekeep.
I just I don't I just don't want weird comments. I didn't want
to say I was a fanboy cuz I don't want weird comments like these
ones. >> You mean the eyeliner brand? I actually don't
even remember. Is that what you're asking me? What eyeliner brand
is it? It's some It's something basic. Okay. It's something very
basic. >> I'm not I'm not that tapped into
the the brands yet. So, I I could get back to you on that. Okay.
I could get I could get back to you on that, but it's it's only
like basic things,
you know? But what else?
Mert wants to call in. Okay. Before we get completely chaotic
and Merk gets called in,
I feel like I should uh >> Dude, let Smaggle call in. Remember
when he used to have Smaggle call in all the time? Is there some
reason he wouldn't want Smaggle to call in for this stream?
are we going to watch anything from his making from tipster of
making from of tipster days?
I have no idea. I I'll be honest. I'm not a lyrics historian.
Let Wyan call in. Dude, why? Where's Wyan? Where's Wyan?
Where is he? He He uh Smaggle used to call in all the time. All
the time. >> I feel like is what what am I supposed to
do? Should I talk? Should I talk to these people? What's up?
Are you auditioning for Zelda?
Zelda, by the way? No. Okay, I'm going to do the At some point,
I want to do a Link Link cosplay. That's been my plan for the
longest time. Um.
>> we
all we all know the version. We all know the version. >> That's
it. That is what I want. That is what I want to do at some at
some point. But I feel like every wig I haven't really experimented
enough. >> I happen to I happen to know this version cuz
somebody mentioned it to me like based on this this uh I think
Chud covering this. Okay. But we all know the >> up with
like wigs for cosplay to fully know. I think that's Kai, isn't
it? >> On me. So, and like every wig I have done, it's
either because I didn't put enough time into it or style it enough,
but it just looks awkward. So, I've been trying to do like every
like cosplay within the bounds of like my own hair, but that
is not I don't think that's going to be good enough, you know,
especially in the long run. Chat, you realize this all happened
because of the performative mail video. Is this He does a Gerudo
Link cosplay. He passed the event horizon. Okay, for people who
like me didn't play Breath of the Wild. Okay, this is the Gerudo
Link cosplay.
It's like this version with the shirt or whatever. Bro, I can't
believe they he's
I mean, you know, that's the one he's going to do, right? That's
like he's basically already got the hair for it.
You know, that's the one he's going to
Cosplay is going the sneaky route, I guess. So,
if he if he I agree.
I agree, Frank, 100%. If he does this, it's over. It's totally
over. I think I saw Finster do this exact cosplay.
>> Can't Can't do it, man. You can't do it, >> Just
being a performative male. >> Can't do it. >> Is
that what a performative male is? >> I don't [laughter]
think I don't think that's in the same category.
Um,
is that lipstick on you, Liam? Just seems like it. No, I don't
have any I don't have any lipstick on. My lips are kind of chapped
right now, to be honest. Every blonde bull cut character cosplay.
Yeah, man. Thank you.
where's your feminist literature infiltrating the gay space?
That's a that's a good way to put it, man. Thank
>> Yes, cuz you're not telling us. >> Just meme through
it, man. Just meme in the room. What? Okay. Ask the qu ask the
Ask the question. What do you want?
>> I want to talk to every cafe because >> be honest.
Have you looked up the price of
Have you? Have you have you looked at the price just like as
a funny have you gone like h I guess I just look it up maybe
to
see does anyone there asked him about voice training >> cuz
every cafe he's [laughter] I think he left a comment on my video
being like this ain't right man
was just like this ain't right
this is not right why do you have makeup okay well I already
do do you want me to repeat myself I already said this in the
pinned comment you could take a look at right here.
The Liam Donovan community is not woke. I think it is for the
most part. The comments were old. Just like we're very nice on
this video, but I already like
Hoodfax TV would be so disappointed. That's so that's so real.
Um, no, but what I said is uh cuz I I did get a lot of question
I did get a lot of questions of like is this coming out of
like closet is are you transitioning or whatever? like a lot
of, you know, genuine people that were asking. Um, so I said,
"And for anyone wondering, no, I'm not trans. Just doing things
to my appearance that I think look cool. Nothing deeper." Lol.
And yeah, that that's basically it. Experimenting for what, though?
You live You live life one more one time, man. You only live
once. What do you mean,
dude? The Alex Gekkmo is like where I was actually going. I needed
to go to look at some of this stuff. Okay. Jesus Christ. One
year of Canada and completely broke commentary's biggest transphobe.
This woman is the devil. [laughter]
Maybe he's just Why is every woman supportive of this? Yeah.
No, I'm thinking, bro, there's nothing that could get me like
in the Myin Gaines group chat faster than women coming in being
like, "Just let this guy transition. What's wrong with that?
What's wrong with him being gay? What's wrong with him painting
his fingernails and wearing some like lip gloss and like some
eyeliner? What's wrong with that? What's wrong with it? What's
wrong with that? Uh, a lot. Okay. A lot. A lot is wrong with
it. Okay. Jesus.
>> What do you What do you mean?
You know, heart of the fanboy comment by the way. True.
>> Um, there there kind of is another explanation for that
though. Like for people who are genuinely >> He didn't
just heart he didn't just heart one fanboy comment. He hearted
a couple fanboy comments. Okay. He wasn't just doing one. He's
doing a couple >> there. There kind of isn't. I just I
think it looks cool. So, that's what I'm uh you know going to
do or present myself that way. Um in addition to like more buying
uh like stylistic cool clothes that I, you know, have been putting
off for a while. Like I've always been wanting to buy like a
lot of different clothes for me to just like style, but like
you know fully experimenting that I I I think I you know I like
the way I look with uh you know makeup on and this stuff. I think
uh
I you know it's it's expedited the process basically.
So
wait, sorry. What was that? I missed something. Um figuring out
what eyeliner brand is also really cool. Okay, I'll get back
to you on that. Okay, I don't know what to tell you. If you wore
eyeliner every day, no one would say anything.
Oh, yeah. Well, you know, of course, I like I plan on doing this
more often. I don't know how consistent it's going to be.
>> Ah.
Uh-huh.
>> Um, but
>> that's the first honest thing I've heard here. Okay.
>> But who did your makeup? Me, man. What do you want from
me? What do you mean of I did it? What are you What are you What
are you asking me? What do you expect me to say? Yeah. Yeah,
I did it. problem.
Okay. No way. B. What is is that hard to believe? Is that hard
to believe? What do you mean, man?
Can you can can't can you look up tutorials?
>> can you can Aren't there tutorials for a reason for
a reason? >> Dude, the the hair the hair flips and stuff.
I feel like I called out the hair flips as being like super
like super feminine coated and a long time ago when I first saw
this guy. I'm pretty sure I said something like that. Yeah, that
guy's transitioning because nobody touches their hair that much.
He's a straight dude. I'm sorry. It's not h It's not happening.
It's not
I'm in waiting, bro. We could get to that. His mom did for him.
Yeah, man. My mom, by the way,
is your hair blonde now? Yeah. To be honest, I don't even know
how much I like the I don't even know how much I like the blonde.
Um I I think it's a fine color. Uh Caitlyn likes it a lot. Isn't
that just a stereo stereotypical thing to do? No. The thing to
do is to not have a long-term girlfriend and then a bunch of
girls at concerts and when you go to like your My Chemical Romance
concert. Okay, that's the thing to do. The thing to do is to
have your girlfriend convince you after you've done like a a
bunch of years of anti-trans like bigoted content to go and paint
your nails and start wearing makeup on stream. That's the thing
to do. Okay. Know the difference. This might save your life one
day. >> Lot more than me. >> Oh, I meant flipping
your hair. Yeah, >> But now, yeah, to be honest, I don't
even know how much I like the I don't even know how much I like
the blonde.
>> Um I I think it's a fine color. Uh Caitlyn likes it
a lot more than me, >> yeah, I heard I heard that his girlfriend
likes it a lot more than him.
>> Yeah, sure.
Again, again, you know, if you're building up the if you're building
up the the logs. Okay.
Another thing, his girlfriend really likes it. What does he like?
I don't know. I like what she >> It's I don't know. Like
I I'm not going to be like keeping it like in like a month or
maybe like two months. I'm going to get rid of it. But uh
it look it looks a lot better when I have like a whole like I
guess look.
He left Turkey Tom to do this. She found Turkey Tom was resistant.
Okay. Turkey Tom resisted the programming. Turkey Tom got the
black fingernail paint and then he [__] off. Okay.
He he painted his fingernails and he was like, "You know what?
This is too much. Can't keep doing it." And he broke out. He
broke out. Turkey Tom got by a fanboy. And Tequila Sunset, of
course, we know that there's only one way to get his masculinity
back, okay? There's only one way for Turkey Tom after his whole
gym arc when he comes out looking like a Roman Roman legionary.
There's only one way for him to get his masculinity back, okay?
And that's to do what every Roman before him has done to the
Greeks. the the GR the Greek twinks. Okay. >> Going on
as opposed to >> it's the only it's the only way. I'm >> Like
nothing at all. >> I hate to I hate to take I had to take
Salvo's side on this one. Okay. But it's the only way for either
of them to be okay going forward. Okay. It's it's all >> it's
written in the stars. I didn't even I didn't write the script.
Okay. This is cosmic. I can't stop it going on as opposed to
like nothing at all.
But what color next? I don't know if I'm going to experiment
a lot of colors because like um
[snorts] this was cool, but to be honest uh honestly it's that's
so fun as a a gender flu person. It's cool to see sis.
Dude, be honest. Be honest.
This comment would make lyrics fly into like a homicidal rage
like six months ago. Honestly, that's so fun. is and a is a gender
fluid person. It's cool to see sis people explore their own fashion
breaking out of gendered orbs. I feel like that would have made
lyrics fly into a rage like a homicidal rage.
And now let's see let's see how let's see how 2025 lyrics going
into 2026 lyrics handles that comment.
this was cool but to be honest uh honestly it's that's so fun
as a agender flu person. It's cool to see sis people.
Sorry, what? Cis people explore their fashion, breaking out of
gender norms. Um,
yeah. Yeah, I am.
Okay, I know what I know what cisgender is, right? That's
uh, I don't even know cis trans. What does this even mean? I
got no idea
what any of this means. I'm just here so I don't get fined, guy.
I just I just put the blush on. I just put the eyeliner on so
my girlfriend wouldn't get mad. Guys, I have no idea what any
of this stuff
>> It's nothing special. Yeah, I I'm sis. I'm I'm >> hot
cages. What are these? What What are these? Oh my god. >> Pretty
sure [laughter] I'm sis, man. I'm sis, by the way.
>> Do we I was thinking of the Nick Andrew clip. The Nickandra
clip with um
Adam is not Adam22.
Whatever. Um, Ymss. Yes. No. But uh, what do you mean get rid
of it? Are you going to dye it something else like vibrant or
natural colors? No, I think I'm just going to go back to like
my natural hair color, but in like ashy way, basically. That's
straight. No, sis is not straight. Is cis straight? Heteron.
I I think that's in terms of gender. Like that's in reference
to gender. Um, Wolf Spain, thanks for the six. Okay, I Wolf Spain,
the queue is closed. Don't worry. Okay, I'm going to get to the
ones from the other day, but >> I'm pretty sure the egg
is cracking. Slash Jay slash Jay, we're not going to we're not
going to joke here,
>> but don't pretend that you don't know. No, I I do I
do know. Like, I roughly do know, but um sis is normal. Sis is
straight for gender. Okay, man. Okay.
No, I I I thought I roughly do know, but I don't want to say
something wrong to give people the wrong idea.
Um
you should try a bunch of colors before going back to natural.
to what I'm
Yeah, I guess so. Oh, normal, by the way. Okay, that's hor Okay,
that's actually a horrible thing to say. I did not mean
I did not mean to say normal. [laughter] Okay,
that is I'm I'm not passing woke. I'm not passing the woke exam
right now. [laughter] I did not. Okay, you know what I mean.
Okay, that's that's so >> We all We all see it, right?
He's like fighting. The old lyrics is somewhere in there. The
old lyrics is somewhere inside of him.
And it's fighting to get out right now. It's raging against the
programming, okay? It's raging against the mind control.
It's like a Dude, I swear to God if he took a photo with flash
photography right now, it would be like get out. Okay, you'd
see his nose stop
You got to get you got to get me out of here, man. You got to
get me out. Get me out.
You have no idea. Social conditioning. Okay, that's that's 20
years of social conditioning actually slipping on live.
Okay, what do you want from me? Okay. You you know what I meant.
You know what I meant. Didn't mean that though. Okay. Of course.
Normal doesn't begin to explain it.
Um I'm normal unlike those queers. Yeah. True, man. Liam is the
MAGA music streamer.
True. Liam Ronnie Radkkey arc. Okay. [laughter] No, but um Okay.
What was I Okay. I I need to find I need to go down a train to
of things to talk about though. So, are you doing emo makeup?
I mean, I don't know. I'm just overall like a experiment of things.
I I can't tell you something specific like probably at some point.
>> Guys, it's just an experiment. We're just We're just
experiment guys. It's just an experiment.
We're just doing a little experimenting.
Holy
I
just experimenting. Liam is my favorite conservative. Average
Dax fan. Yeah, you know it, man. >> Um when are we getting
the drawing stream? Yeah, tonight was just late. Um so I I didn't
feel like I wanted to start it late, but don't worry. like next
stream is going to be drawing as well. Um the the main thing
I'm happy about is uh
is like getting both set up now on Twitch and YouTube officially.
So I'm just kind of like very excited about that. So bro, it
takes two seconds to register a Twitch channel. What the [__]
are you talking about?
[__] are you talking about, dog? How is this Okay.
How is this even remotely something that's difficult or
what is it? What is this, bro? I It took me so long. It took
me so long to set up a Twitch channel. How the
did it take so long? What?
What? What?
Okay, apparently from here we've got
What do we got? We've got the Hold on a second. Oh, I have more
time stamps, but this is a long stream. I see why we've got so
many clips now, though.
A lot of clips. This stream goes on for a while. I only have
a couple more time stamps.
>> here I'll go to the I'll jump to the next one. Seems
like we're probably going to be chilling for a minute, so I'll
jump to the next one. >> Do you have any? >> Apparently
he gets a call. >> Plans who you're going to cosplay as
here. Yeah, I I want to talk about that more here. I'll do that
a little bit later, though. But okay, I think that's good. Okay.
Is that over? Okay. Is the
Is the elephant address addressed? Meow for stream. Okay. Mertz.
See, this is this guy's problem, man.
Hold on. Hold on. Did I Wait, did I see that in Twitch chat?
>> Do you have any plans who you're going to cosplay as
here? Yeah, I I want to talk about that more here. I'll do that
a little bit later, though. >> Oh, I see. Hold on.
This guy said, "Can you say ny?"
>> But okay, I think that's good. Okay. Is that over? Okay.
Is the
Is the elephant address addressed? Meow for stream.
>> Oh, this is the meet guy. This guy who asked to call
in before. Meow for stream, please. See, this is this guy's problem,
man.
This is this guy's problem, to be
Um,
but yeah. All right, though. Okay, moving on. Moving on. Boom.
Let's see. But there you go. All right. Top comment, by the way.
Why [laughter] did this become top? This is basically Queman's
chat. That was Babka who asked for nya.
Damn >> comments. Okay, [laughter] I liked this comment
when it had like a few likes.
Why is this the top comment now? I'm waiting. Okay, here. Let's
see. Every cafe, mister. All right, Ever Cafe. All right, Ever
Cafe. Let's get this guy to call in. Let's see. What is What
is this guy? What does this guy got to say? Hello. Hello.
>> Anyone? Anyone there? Anyone out there?
>> How you doing?
>> Can you hear me?
I can hear you, >> bro. Doing these full captures of Discord
is exactly how all of these people leak DMs like all the time.
It's so crazy doing like these full Discord captures.
I don't I don't know why people do it to be honest with you.
Like I I literally pop the window out. It's so easy to pop the
window out for like calls and [__] You just pop the
window out and then you're never going to leak any of your chats
ever. >> Well, question every cafe. But yeah, what's what's
that, man? >> Have you ever seen Star Wars: The Clone
Um, is that the animation one?
>> I think so. >> In the prequels.
>> I think so.
>> Yeah. So, there's a character in that show that I really
liked growing up that died in the show. And then when Disney
bought the show because George Lucas is really dumb and sold
it to a company that had no soul, they brought back the character
and he was what I like to call and what everyone in the fandom
likes to call character assassinated. your appearance right now.
It's I don't know, man. It's It's getting there. [laughter] We're
getting close to >> Okay,
so Kai is who the [__] was it? I forget who the Kathy
Kathleen Kennedy. Is that who it was? That's who Kai is Kathleen
Kennedy and she's destroying everybody in commentary. Okay, she's
just wait until you see what she does to Dioro 3 years from now.
It's going to be disastrous. Okay, it's going to be [__]
dire.
>> Victor assassination. Dude, why do you have mascara
on your eyes?
>> What? What happened, dude? I >> Huh? What are
you What are you, man? A character assassination? What are you
talking about, man? >> Liam Liam, I was I was literally
like I was going to tell you like, oh, dude, I was so excited
for another call-in. I see on Twitter, right? I go on Twitter
for like the first time ever in like a few days and I see a post
from Smaggle Daggle of you >> wearing like mascara and
I'm like what the [snorts] what happened? >> Okay. Is Is
this your call-in, man? Is this your >> dude? What is it?
Is this your call-in, man? Is this your Is this your callin,
bro? It's so over. It's actually just so
>> It's so unbelievable, dude.
This is the guy who pressed Britney Simon. It was like
literally calling her a hag to her face.
How the previously
not mighty maybe, but dude, what the what a falloff.
What an incredible falloff. What the What is this? Don't worry
about it.
>> Dude, dude, >> why are you mad? Why are you angry?
>> I know. I know. Last month you confirmed to me that
you were trans. And you know what? I >> Oh, is that what
I did? Is that what I did? Can you show me where I >> was
while I was debating hot takes? I like I >> Yeah, I told
her I think I What I said was like um you were like gaslighting
me about man.
>> It's called growth. Now you don't understand with the
cage on that's growth is the one thing he can't do
And then I said to a woman, "You're not a woman, you're a man."
And you said, "Whoa, whoa, whoa. That's not true." And then you
started laughing and I was like, I'm talking about you and then
you didn't deny what I said. >> Okay. Well, Ever Cafe,
it sounds like this going to be a problem for you, man.
>> Okay, hold on. Uh, Shadow, since you're brand new to
the channel, this is a YouTuber who used to be a commentary YouTuber,
pretty anti-trans, pretty anti-LGBT. He got a girlfriend who
was like a goth like uh a goth girlfriend who dated other members
of the same community and got them to paint their nails and come
close to wearing mascara and too. And now she's doing it to this
guy. And this guy used to be the this guy used to be super transphobic.
Hold on. I think Can I grab that Shamu clip again? Let me grab
that Shamu clip. I'll show you an old clip of this guy talking
about trans people. Okay.
Oh, not that one. Yeah, this one. This one? This one? I think.
>> But what if he
>> This is him from before >> by this little [__]
in a dress aka
>> you guys sending me. Come on, man. This >> So
this is him getting sent this picture before of his of his audience
suggesting that he might be trans. The Charlie Kirk song. I didn't
recognize it until you pointed it out. I didn't recognize the
song until you pointed out. >> Come on, man. Get this away
from me. >> This guy's a little
like Jaden. He's just a little like a little fem. He wears skirts
to school. He diapers. He's basically got a big He cries all
day about he wishes he was a girl. Like, bro, just get surgery.
Just get a customuilt
and get [__] bro. He's sucking
[clears throat] on just like that. Keep sucking, bro. Little
[__] Suck my penis. Actually, no. Suck my That'll
be your first. But what if he >> Jesus? Total Femian's
victory, bro. They get everybody in the end. Okay,
this is why this is why you never face reveal. Okay, they get
every single one of these fanboy creators in the end. Every single
one of these twinks,
the the hit squad of like Femos and Bunk and who the [__]
the other guy. Oh, synth. They get they get everybody, okay?
They put their they get their claws into you, they get you in
the end. That's they'll get you. Okay. Wait, I was told to work
this picture in at some point. This seems like a good Wait, who's
the Who's the guy? Who's that kid who always talks to them? I
forget. [laughter]
Not the one you were thinking of. That I'm sorry. That's absolutely
disgusting. We didn't need to see that. Nobody needed to see
that ever. Okay, we just Nobody needed to see that ever. I'm
subbing. Okay, chill, bro. Chill, bro.
Oh my goodness. So, anyway, you get the idea. That's the quick
overview. We're going to listen to more of this call. This guy
must be from his old community. Why is he taking Collins from
his old community if he's on the music channel now? He shouldn't
be He shouldn't be referencing this anymore. >> Not gonna
be able Not gonna be able to watch the channel anymore. I don't
Well, I don't know. I don't know what to tell you, man. >> No,
no. I I don't have any issues with it. I just want to know why
you're wearing makeup, bro. >> Okay. Are you watching the
stream? I just You want me to just repeat myself? Am I Am I my
the pinned comment? >> No, I I I heard what you said. It's
just I don't know if it's like,
you know, like the actual like, you know, thing.
>> I will just be your pig. >> Oh [__]
>> Reuben donated $3. Dang. Brittany Simon looked hot in
that pig. >> I Mhm. Okay. You need to
>> You need to chill. You need to chill. Not a mistake
for the gifted sub. Let's go. Let's go. Let's go.
>> I I already said in the pin comment, dude. What do you
What do you want from me? You want me to repeat myself for the
whole stream?
>> No, just keep it brief. Just tell me like your true
honest opinion on why you're wearing makeup, bro. >> Why
do you Why do you wear Why do you pick out shirts that you like?
>> Cuz they look cool. Cuz they look cool. You like the
way they look. And Yeah. >> I pick out shirts that are
comfortable for me. Cuz I hate specific fabric, right? So, I
wear shirts that are >> Wait, that's how I pick shirts,
too.
this is uh
what what a giga chat. I just wear the most comfy shirts >> for
me to wear. Okay, man. Okay, if you Well, if you've ever made
a decision for like, hey, I >> No, hold on. I I wear comfy
shirts that actually look okay. They're like uh good, though.
That's actually not true. I have a bunch of buttons up button-ups
that aren't comfy. But in terms of t-shirts that I wear every
day that like if I don't have to go anywhere, those are all comfy.
Okay. >> I want to wear this thing cuz it's cool. if that's
that's the same. >> Do you want an update for the uh the
job
>> Okay. I think Okay. I think we're gonna have to get
back to that. Okay. May maybe not this stream, but I'm I'm very
much looking forward to that in the >> I got it. >> You
got the job. >> I'm like 75% sure. They were telling me
like in a few days we're going to do a background check and then
we're going to give you your your uh uniform. So yeah, I'm pretty
sure I got it. >> Huge huge praise. I'm hope I'm hoping
big things for you. Okay. Here we we'll talk about that more
another stream. Okay. I appreciate that. >> All right.
That's fine. >> Thank you. [snorts] Have a Have a good
one. Thank you. Oh, wait. Oh, >> wait. You're going to
hang up on me. >> Well, I How long did you want this call
to be? I thought this was a quick call.
>> We usually have our calls for like 10, 15 [snorts] minutes.
>> There's people throw There's people throwing tomatoes.
There's people throwing tomatoes at you right now, man. They're
angry. >> If you want, you want. >> The The people
throwing tomatoes have financial investment. Okay. They financially
invested in getting him to this place. STOP [__]
IT UP. STOP [__] IT UP. I'm throwing tomatoes >> You're
dragging your boy your your friend Mert if you want to. >> Yeah,
man. Is that so?
>> Okay, man. Okay. >> Uh, this M person seemed pretty
invested in him being trans. So, >> well, thank you. I
got I Okay, I'll I'll catch up with you another time. >> Fine.
You better not skip my Reddit post this time. >> True.
All right, >> bro. These people are so entitled. You get
like decapitated in my community for being this entitled. That's
crazy. >> Thanks, man. Thank you. Well, well,
>> What's up, dude? >> Well, where are you, man?
>> I'm at a housewarming right now. >> A housewarming?
>> Why are you watching? >> That's it. I
Are you sure? This person seemed really invested earlier. >> My
stream. Dude, this is the problem with you, man. It's like you're
on vacation. You're at the beach. You have my stream on. you're
calling in, which you know, I appreciate the support to a certain
extent,
>> but you're you're just at a family you're like at a
family gathering and you're calling in like you're you sneak
away to the bathroom to call in. Come on, man. >> You're
so weird.
>> I'm weird, man.
>> I try to like go away. I try to like, you know, not
watch and not type and not like debate and then you just do this.
>> Is this is this your calling? Any anything you want
to say to the, you know, good people or the the to the topic
of the stream? >> What even is the topic? Eh, >> you
suck. >> What are you streaming for? >> You're the
worst. >> You're you're such a racist, man. >> What
are you see? Okay, this is the problem with you, man. You just
Okay. All right. All right.
I think that that's all I had for time stamps on the stream.
Okay. Now, hold on. I think from this I think from this we have
to go to this part, right? So, you heard at the beginning of
that where the people in chat were telling him to meow repeatedly,
right? You guys hear that?
You guys hear that part? I don't
I don't meow for anyone.
Mert. It's the same guy. That's the guy who just called in. The
guy who was at the housewarming. [laughter] >> Okay. I
would never meow. I would never meow for anyone.
>> It's soing over.
It's just It's never been more over. Okay, we already showed
We already showed Trans Aiden on stream. Don't link Trans Aiden
anymore. That's crazy.
Orbell, I'm looking at you. Stop linking Trans Aiden now. Okay.
Never more. Never again. Never again.
Never again.
It's one of the replies. It's one of the replies to
the Shimu tweet. My goodness. My god. My god. I will just be
your pay. >> Hello, Ruben. Ruben with a donation. >> Donated
$3. Mo greater than meow. >> Wait, what? Maro greater than
Oh, I get it. I get it. Mau greater than meow.
I got it.
I got it. This is why you have to cultivate a viciously transphobic
audience so they will never ever attempt to groom you into being
a woman. Okay, this is exactly this is like you just need to
cultivate the most
that's not that's not all of you. That's not even most of you.
Okay, that's a joke. It's a joke. It's a joke. Take end. It's
a joke. It's a joke. It's a joke. It's a joke.
That was a joke.
That's not real. It's just a little meme. I think I've gone through
a lot of the stuff around this. Hold on. Let me see if I got
anything else.
I don't think I have anything else on this one. Lyrics. Anything
else? No.
Oh, I would say
the fact that he used to like a lot of stuff. Absolutely. Biggest
red flag, right? That he used to be on Twitter liking art and
then he art all over Twitter. Yeah. Huge red flag. Massive red
flag. A woman be a woman being cool with this out of the blue
makes no sense. My money is on Kai. Well, what do you mean your
money's on K? on Kai. How How could you even possibly believe
it's not Kai when Turkey Tom is Turkey Tom still painting his
fingernails?
Or is that stopped? Because if Turkey Tom's fingernails aren't
black right now, then I feel like we could say there's a good
We have a good idea that this is not serious. That it just has
to be her, right? That like this is you can't be serious doubting
it.
See you later, Jtock. See you later, Kico. Have a good one.
It has to be her, right? It just it's the only thing that makes
sense. She did his makeup. She's the one who picked the hair
color, dyed his hair. He also couldn't name the eyeliner, implying
his girl did it for him. Well, I have also been told multiple
women in chat now have confirmed that the the eyeliner has done
really well in a way that like a man is not going to do it on
a first try. Or there's two options, okay? Either this guy's
been binge watching makeup tutorials for weeks now,
probably more of a red flag, or his girlfriend did it. Okay,
I'm going to hope his girlfriend did it cuz the other the other
reality here is worse.
Okay,
the the other the other option is not good. We get odds on a
credible underage grooming allegation coming out within 12 months.
I How old was Kai when when Lyrics and her hooked up the first
time?
Because Tom was young, right? Tom was like 20, 21. Kai's got
to be Kai's got to be pretty young. She's older than him. Okay.
Okay. All right. You can't just watch tutorials. That is a practiced
hand. Okay, I believe it. How old is this girl? Uh, it sounds
like 20. Must be Dude, how old is Lyric? I actually don't know
lyrics is age. So, >> Reban Ruben donated $3. Maybe he's
binge watching makeup tutorials. Maybe it's
>> Damn. You always throw me off, man. Y'all always throw
me off. Hold on. Hold on. Hold on. I'm I'm told I'm being told
to look at something. Okay. Okay. Hold on. I I I got suggested.
I searched something in the transcript.
>> Now I have to click in here. Okay. He's talking about
cosplay here at the end of the stream.
>> I mean, I might be cool just like to experiment with
this, but please watch the clips. What clip? How do I even watch
them? What do you mean?
>> What do you mean? Goth makeup next? I mean, I'm not
really I don't really have >> Uh, no. Shadow. I There was
a joke about being overtly transphobic. You can't be that base.
You're okay. Keep it to yourself a little bit. Keep it to maybe
even keep it to yourself a lot. I'll be honest. This is actually
not as transphobic a place as as I joke about.
Follow my lead. Oh, I am the line. Go no further than the line.
Okay. >> Planned. Um
but it would be cool just like to experiment with things, I guess.
Um to see how it looks. But yeah, nothing's like planned or anything.
>> Goth makeup next. Well, you know, I don't know where
the line h we'll have to experiment with some stuff. Don't worry,
it gets better. It gets better. It gets better.
>> Makeup streams could be cool. I don't think I'm going
to do makeup streams that like doing my makeup on stream. I don't know
if I I don't know if I feel comfortable doing that. It's like,
dude, he's honestly he's honestly just setting up flags for his
fundraising events. Uh $1,000 in donations, guys, so we can do
a makeup stream.
>> Uh-huh. I don't know. It's the makeup for content. No,
drag makeup. I'm not really I'm not really a drag. Like I like
dressing up in drag guy, I think. At least so far. >> At
least so far. Well, you know, so far at least so far. I'm not
really
brother
Dude, to be honest,
at this point, how do we We just got to call.
Who's the aberration?
Dude, I You can't You can't give an inch to these people. This
entire commentary community. There's just something sinister
about this entire commentary community. Uh, all of them, like
all of the fans of this commentary community, every single There's
something. You cannot give an inch on this. The second you give
an inch, you are down the river. You are done.
Never ever ever ever ever
wear the cat ears. Never say meow when they ask you to. Never
say never do any of these things. Okay? You cannot you cannot
give one inch on this. It's over the second you do.
>> Did you do it yourself? Yes, I did. Why does everybody
keep asking that? >> Cuz [snorts] we know you're lying.
>> Think I went to a makeup stylist?
>> We think your girlfriend did it. Hold on. Best part
coming up. >> Mr. You got to stop, man. Mr. You got to
stop. Dude, you got to leave me alone. >> Wait, wait, wait,
wait, wait, wait, wait. What did Mert say? Hold on. What did
Mert say? Why you lying, bro? Why you lying, bro? >> M,
you got to stop, man. M, you got to stop. You got to leave me
alone.
When are you showing the cosplay photos,
Cuz it's better than most people have experienced. Thank you.
I I I will show like the like, you know, short cosplayed. I cosplayed
as um
cinema cinema roll cinema roll. I used to call it cineamoral
as a kid,
but I cosplayed as cinema roll and uh like a pseudo misa thing,
but it wasn't really that good of a cosplay. It's like a pseudo
version of Misa. So, so, so, so he's not saying like Death Note.
There's no way, right? There's no way. There's It's just not
possible that he could mean Death Note right there, right?
Like a pseudo Misa. You guys know who I'm talking about, right?
>> And uh like a pseudo Misa thing, but it wasn't really
that good of a cosplay. It's like a pseudo version of Misa. >> Wait,
did he say miso? This is This is Cinema Roll. Cinema roll. Cinema
roll. Hello Kitty wiki. He cosplayed as this. I mean, this is
dude. Okay.
But then he said a pseudo misa.
He's not saying like there's no way he could possibly meet Miso
from Death Note, right? There's just no possible way
cuz like the hair unfortunately for him, he's kind of got the
hair for it.
There's just no possible way that this is who he could mean.
It's not poss I don't think so. I I think he's got to mean something
else here.
He's got He's got to mean something else here. >> The cinema
roll was cool, though. >> Hold on. Let's Let's listen to
it again. Cosplay cinema roll. >> Cosplayed. I cosplayed
his um
cinema cinema roll. >> No, no, no, no, no, no. Hold on,
hold on, hold on. He actually does say it. >> Cine cinema
roll. Cinema roll. I used to call it cineor roll as a kid.
>> but I cosplayed as cinema roll. And uh
>> so cinema roll and one other character >> like
a pseudo Misa thing, but it wasn't really that good of a cosplay.
It's like a pseudo version of
Misa.
there's no [__] There's no way. There's no way. There's
just no brother.
What is he doing? Okay, I say what is he doing? It's very obvious
what he's doing. He is just He is just monetizing the thing that
he has been scared to monetize for the past what, like year and
a half, two years. Bro,
is this clip on Twitter?
Has nobody clipped this?
I guess nobody watched all the way to the end or what? Because
I I've not seen this clip yet. I've seen a bunch of other clips.
I didn't see this clip. The Oh, you haven't put up yet, Shimu.
Well, there it is.
>> The cinema roll was cool, though. Do you have a cinema
roll plush? Multiple. No, this is good. And it's nice and >> Okay,
that's another massive red flag. That's another massive red flag.
That's a huge red flag. What the What's the dono threshold for
you starting a course of estrogen? Uh, realistically nothing.
Realistically, I It's the same thing as like, okay, you could
try to offer me that, but realistically, I always have the stake
rip cord to pull before that rip cord. So, like if you'd have
to offer me like significantly more than stake somehow, and then
I don't want that, but I do like money. So, like stake is just
always the easy safe out, right? I could just gamble.
I could I could literally just gamble. That's the That's the
way out. That's the way you make money. You wouldn't suck a dick
for a million dollars. Yeah. Sucking a for like I don't know
if a million is the right mark. It's probably not that far away,
but like that's way different. That's that's incredibly different.
That's not modifying your body chemistry in some way, bro. You
could suck a dick, you get some mouthwash, you're fine. Okay,
you take estrogen, you like start transitioning. That's way different.
I see gambling like sucking dick. Okay. It's like one of those
things where it's like, yeah,
it's bad, but ultimately your soul your soul well gambling is
probably worse on the soul than sucking to be honest.
I'm just going to be real. At least when you suck, you don't
ruin like multiple other people's lives. Okay. It's just all
on >> Speric. It's just I don't really It doesn't fully
like stand out to me. Give me like scratch that itch is all you
>> I will wait. >> You have no idea how bad it really
is. You have no idea how bad it >> mean like scratch that
itch is all you know I will say so >> what itch is he scratching
tried to flag the term gender queer bro yeah it's a big deal
>> it's like a another like six to 6.5 basically like solid
but it just doesn't fully scratch that itch for me so yeah give
me your numbers give me your numbers on that one that's me Ezra
Marian for the five let's take a look at this okay [snorts] but
yeah I do want to show like photos of Uh, bro, he straight up
he straight up listened to that song, commented 0% on the song,
and just talked about the things he wants to do with cosplay
and about his transitioning
or purported neverly never
Okay, I Bro, what are you paying for there? You I mean, I shouldn't
really talk. I guess I I take money for He just listened to the
music. Watch me listen to music while wearing makeup and transitioning
slowly over time. That's what this business model is. It's Finster,
but you can't pay me to listen to music.
Cool. Cool.
>> The cosplays because I also want cosplay to be part
of like content stuff and eventually like play piano in public
at cosplays and whatever, which could be super cool. And maybe
even do like meetups there depending on, you know, long future
or something. That could be like super cool. Is he good at playing
piano? At least
he could get away if he was good enough at playing piano, which
I assume he's not, but if he's good enough at playing piano,
he could maybe get away with some of this. Maybe. >> That's
like my uh long plan goals. That could be fun. >> You're
a good enough artist, you can get away with being like really
really really queer. Okay. For lack of a better
You You just can. Great artists, they can get away with that
[__] So, uh Okay. What's this song though? Seeing
Stars, Jessica Lay Mayfield. >> Yeah. Yeah. But I don't
know how good he is at piano.
Wait, is he is he actually really good at it? Yeah, Prince. Yeah,
exactly. That That's his out. Okay, that's his out. >> Learn
Vocaloid songs, do Migo cosplay. Yeah, that's what I want. >> Although,
I will say probably not his out because I think unfortunately
for him, he put on the record so heavily that he didn't want
this that he didn't that this was like gross and it grossed him
out and all of this [__] Oh no.
Oh no. I just heard him talking about more women >> learn
Vocaloid songs to do Migu Cosplay. Yeah, that's what I want to
do is like that's what I want to upload on the second channel
which I changed the name to Liam.
>> Uh Shimu, you still here? You catch that one? You catch
that one? This is who he just said he was going to cosplay. So
very cool. Very awesome. Hey, I I I totally want to do a Meiku
cosplay, guys. I want to do a Hatsuni Miku costume. Let's go.
Let's go.
>> You win. Space Ghost, thank the gifted sub to Tequila
Sunset. >> W Thank you. >> Thank you.
>> Learn Vocaloid songs, do Migu Cosplay. Yeah, that's
what I want to do is like that's what I want to upload on the
second channel which I changed the name to Liam Liam Dunovan
everything instead of Liam Dunovan too because I want to post
a lot of stuff like that playing piano in public or just overall
like
>> cosplay content in some way.
>> Bro, he has to Okay, hold on. Hold on. Wait. He could
totally save it. He could totally save this, guys. All right.
All he has to do is say that he doesn't know who Miku is or Vocaloid.
He just has to pretend he doesn't know what Vocaloid is. What
Miku is. Okay. And then he's fine. He can just pretend. He didn't
just admit to wanting to cosplay another woman. [singing]
>> Did you do your hair yourself? Like dyeing it? Oh, no.
No. No. I I went to a professional stylist for bleaching it.
cuz we can never [singing]
>> So far, this is pretty cool. Liam Miku
>> Liam Mikuven.
Yeah, I definitely do want to do a Meiku cosplay, but um
maybe a gender bent version or in between. I'm not sure yet.
>> Oh no, he totally jumped at the idea of doing like he
knows exactly who Miku is. He knows exactly who that is. And
then he's like, "Well, no, maybe, but I'll do it as a guy." Or
like in between, I guess. Dude,
this guy's cooked. It's This guy is cooked. He's cooked. He's
cooked. He's
>> Mikuo is the gender. Ben Miku. Look him up. Yeah, I've
seen it before. Is that the official name though?
All the [singing] days we've spent.
Yeah, for sure.
>> This is Yeah, this is good. But again, it just feels
like it's missing something which is so disappointing cuz it's
like this is like the best song
>> so far I think tonight. >> But it's just like
missing something for me to go crazy about it. But this is like
a cool like seven 7.5
>> if one should try [singing] to leave the
>> I also want to cosplay as like the Vocaloid Ren and
Lens too. Their outfits are so cool.
>> I totally want to do that. I'm so
>> Okay. Okay. Okay. Okay. Okay. I wonder why they called
I'm just I'm going to pull it over from the Google search so
you can see cuz like while they aren't really young in all of
the pictures, they're really young in a lot of the pictures.
Oh, whatever. Whatever. Whatever.
>> dude, this is where the gold was right at the end of
this.
>> Does Kaitlin cosplay? Yeah, we're both getting into
it kind of like the same time or whatever. She did an awesome
L cosplay. Uh, too.
Ah, >> there's no way that she did L and he did Misu. Misa.
Come on, Matt.
She did L and he did Misa. He didn't do Light. He's literally
got the light hair. If he just if he colored his hair for the
cosplay, he's got the exact hair for Light and he's like, "You
know what? I I want to do Misa. I just I want to do Misa actually."
Uh,
no, no, no, no. The way the conversation went, she was like,
"I'm going to do L." And he was like, "Nice. I'm going to do
Light. We're going to be awesome." And she's like, "No, you're
going to do Misa. You're you're going to do Misa. Actually, I
hope you know I hope you know that you're going to do me. No,
no, no. Liam, Liam, Liam, stop arguing with me. You're going
to do Misa where it looked so good. It looks so good and accurate.
Hers was so much better than mine. [snorts] Um,
it was so cool. No, this girl's voice though is great. She has
a great tone. Like, it sounds super good. It just feels like
melodically something in the song is just like missing for me
to go crazy about it. But, this is like a really solid song and
creates a great atmosphere.
probably got like 7.5 easily.
We need photos, bro.
Yeah, I do. Uh I'll post them. I'll post them soon. Uh within
Yeah. Okay. All right.
I mean, I'm just going to say it. Start a Patreon. Okay.
You You might as well just go all the way. The The biggest mistake,
okay, most people make is they just wait too long to monetize.
Just monetize it now. Just monetize it now.
Okay.
We know you wanna We know you wanna Hold on. Where am I? Here
>> in the next like couple of streams, you
>> Um, you know, I'm going to post in my Instagram, too,
to be honest. Maybe I'll just do that, >> like official.
Yeah, I should just post my Instagram, to be honest. That would
be a good way to promote the Instagram,
Um, toy chica cosplay.
Could you imagine how magical it would be
for a toy,
guys? Could you imagine a Toy Chica
Imagine it's just so magic. So magical. Wouldn't that be magical,
guys? Wouldn't that be so magical?
>> That would be so magical.
But that's awesome. But this chorus is great though.
>> Liam, do VK makeup? Specifically '90s. Um, I don't know
what that is. What is that? What do you think of their new album,
Private Music? I actually haven't heard it. I have heard good
things about it, though. [screaming] >> I'm just I'm looking
for anything in the in the transcript right now. This other stuff
here. How do you know who these ninjas are? Or how do you know
what these things are? I'm googling them as he says them. Well,
for some of them, for the last couple, I knew who Hatsune Miku
was, though.
I was I don't know. Do a lot of people not know who Hatsune Miku
is? I knew who Miku was because the they like broke records in
Japan for her concerts. And
that's that'd be surprising if you just didn't know who that
was. Normal people don't. I thought it was like,
bro, Japanese people used to go wild.
Miku
Hollowo concert. Oh, she's at
>> Oh, she was at Coachella.
You tell me normies don't know who this person is. It's also
how they do concerts for her.
>> K, start the projection thing. >> They do like
the hologram concerts.
Got
to be like a hyper weep to be into
>> Yeah, I thought I thought Hats Miku had like broad appeal
was like like popular way more popular than a lot of other Japanese
like culture.
I kind of thought she gone like pretty wide, but maybe not. Miku's
music is huge on TikTok. Everyone knows. Yeah. U maybe I'm I'm
just like online, I guess. Pretty online. Thought it was a real
person when you said a concert. No. Oh, also do we need to check
out Iron Mouse's concert? I heard Iron Mouse's concert at Twitch.
or at the streamer a rewards was god awful. Do we need to take
a look at that or was that god awful?
I heard it was god awful.
Oh, also I think was it qual came in and asked if we saw partway
through did you come across the part where his chat get him to
admit he is by?
No, I did not see that. The part where his chat get him to admit
he is by lyrics is just regular. No, Larry knew who Miku was.
Lar literally knew who Miku was because somebody said it again
and he was like, "Oh yeah, I want to do Miku." Maybe a gender
bent version or somewhere in between. He knew who Mik He knew
Miku was a woman when he was like, "Yeah, I want to do House
Miku." He saw that Spotify wrapped it one. Okay, here we already
went over the Spotify raps at another time, but um Liam confirming
he's p
Okay.
Yes. Oh, we finally struck gold on the subreddit. Yes, man.
Finally,
we [snorts] finally struck gold. Sorry, the clip is kind of quiet.
I don't know if he's talked about this in other videos or posts,
but small clip from a stream a few days ago. Debatable whether
he's by because everyone in his audience is gay or is everyone
in his audience gay because he's
many such
What is the question? Yeah, it's very funny because I I've never
talked about like anything um explicitly, but it's like [laughter]
people make um
I don't know comments.
That's so philosophical. True. How'd you go from covering Blackula
to this Leon? Okay, thank you for the two, man. That's a
Is that a reference to That's a reference to the um Oh, what
the [__] was it? the Mama Max stuff, right? Camden
Gerard Davis. Is that who that was? I didn't cover any of I didn't
watch any of that stuff. That was when I was first getting into
streaming. That's who he's talking about, right? Yeah. Okay.
Okay. Okay. Okay. I didn't cover any of that.
Dude, I wonder if there were flags that he might have been by.
Like that Shimu clip that I've watched twice now and I'm going to
watch a third time right now.
Literally going to watch it again.
>> hold on. Hold on. Hold on. >> But what if he got
by this
address aka
>> the [__] are you guys sending me? Come on,
man. Get this away from me. This guy's a little
like Jaden. He's just a little like a little fem. He wears skirts
to school. He his diapers. He's basically got a big He cries
all day about he wishes he was a girl. Like, bro, just get surgery.
Just get a customuilt
and get [__] bro. Keep sucking.
[clears throat] Just like that. Keep sucking, bro.
Suck my Actually, no. Suck my That would be your first suck.
>> But what if he got owned? >> Good comment. But
what is this weird thing to assume about someone? I mean, to
be honest, it's not really It's not really that uh weird to assume.
Make Twitch bigger. Do you Okay. Do you want Are the Twitch chatters
not pleased? Do you want me to make Twitch
>> Is that what you want? I just ask like why if he was
going to cut part of his camera or if he's going to cut stuff
over here, why is his camera this high? Like cut off at the shoulders,
bro.
Why are you Why do you have all of your mic and everything in
here? You don't need that. Maybe if you're playing piano, you
need it. Oh, maybe he turns to play piano.
But I haven't I haven't seen him turn to play piano at all of
>> Here. Okay, I'll I'll make the chat a little bit bigger.
If it's draining, that's no problem at all. You said it was true
in the clip. Oh, did I already say that? Oh, whoops. If it's
draining, that's no problem at all. I thought Liam was by. True.
That is true.
Not about not standing up for it in a conversation. A lot of
people Wait. Okay. I've already just said this. Okay.
Okay. [laughter]
Wait. When When did I say that? Well, okay. I was on autopilot
this stream.
Okay. That was auto that was autopilot.
Okay, man. That was autopilot. Not caring about not standing
up for it in a conversation allows people who support taking
rights being big to be vocal.
All right. I head cannon. Liam is being You didn't have to, man.
Tell Whoa.
[snorts] Are you by or pan, Liam? Okay. What What's even the
diff what's even the difference? Okay. Uh,
so we've got this lyrics video. He shows up. He's got the He's
got the makeup on.
one day ago. It's about Sabrina Carpenter and Taylor Swift and
their different approaches to having their music taken by President
United States Donald Trump. Hello everyone. Welcome back to the
channel. A lot of changes. You look at uncensored pics. No, I
didn't. But I did have Morau draw in explicit detail via MS Paint
what was what the situation was. Okay, I don't really need to.
I I already saw it. Okay, I basically saw it. is a lot of changes
are going on here. A lot of huge things. Okay, but anyways, I
don't know if you've heard the news or not, but the government
of one of the most powerful countries in the world has been getting
into a lot of Twitter drama lately. A lot of Twitter beef drama
and has resorted to the level of like 14-year-old edgy posting
online. It's terrible. where in attempts to engage the youth,
I suppose, and popularize ICE and what they're doing, they've
been posting a lot of meme videos of them chasing down and arresting
what they call illegals with popular music playing in the background
of the most popular stars in the world. Where in this recent
case, it's Sabrina Carpenter who they're going at. >> Hey,
did did he say illegals? >> Of them chasing down and arresting
what they call legals with popular >> they call legals.
No, illegals. Ill eagles. their music playing in the background
of the most popular stars in the world where in this recent case
it's Sabrina Carpenter who they're going at but they've been
doing this for a long time and it's gotten so bad to the point
where white
>> or
is he doing a slight voice thing? Is there a slight softness
to it now or is it just me?
I don't think so. spokespeople have came out and admitted that
they are purposely rage bait posting to invoke a reaction from
these celebrities to get more attention to their movement. Yes,
this is the level we're at. Higherups admitting to rage posting
rage bait on the timeline. And you know, I don't even talk about
politics or whatever. Like
>> he always he always sounds this soft. I'm sorry. He
always sounded this soft. There's a reason. >> Airbus A350
just tipped $5.
Lyrics. Hold up. Pull up. Pull up.
Thank you so much for the $5. I really appreciate it. Thank you.
Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. >> Rage bait.
>> Um, he always did like he always spoke this way. There's
a reason. Again, we'll get to the Alec Gunter stuff, okay? I've
got the the Alec Gunter clips where Alec Gunter talked about
this guy like thinking about getting in the app and addressed
and shalked about how he was a fem. I trust me, there was always
people who suggested this about him, okay? It's always been there.
It's always been underlying everything. >> Yes, this is
the level we're at. Higherups admitting to rage, posting rage
bait on the timeline. And you know, I don't even talk about politics
or whatever like mainly on this channel. Like when it comes up
with obvious people like Tom McDonald or whatever, I talk about
it. But it's like I'm not a person who's like getting into the
weeds into politics on this channel. But it's stuff like this
that is the most surface level of the surface level. How could
you not find this so deeply embarrassing that the that our government
is being ran this way?
>> Have you ever tried this one? Have you ever tried this
one? Have you ever tried this one? But Sabrina Carpenter publicly
responded to this saying, "This video is evil and disgusting.
Do not ever involve me or my music to benefit your inhumane agenda."
And this is one of the biggest tweets that like the platform
has seen in the longest time. 150 million views, 1.8 million
likes. And at this point, the tweet was actually deleted assumingly
because of some copyright cease or desist or something that Sabrina
Carpenter and her team put out to them. But there's a lot of
different conversations and what the He's trans now. Um, well,
I think he's going to argue he's not trans, probably,
but I mean,
this is how it starts with every single one of these guys.
It's how it's how it starts every single time. And every single
This is like uh this is like there's a couple different things
like this is when you start leaning into like jokes on the internet,
you never come back from that. When you start leaning into there's
one other one. Oh, the stuff. If you like Adam 22 leading into
the thing, I'm sure he thought, "Hey, I'm gonna like bring this
back eventually. It's all going to be fine. It's like for a little
money right now." It's
no, it you don't come back. And I think that's what this is.
Okay.
I think that's what this is.
He's going to make a joke. He's going to make jokes about it.
He's going to be like, "I just want to lean into it once." Nope.
If this disgusted you, you would you would revile it. You would
never do it. But realistically, this is all just telling us that
a little bit underneath the surface when Alec Gunter told you
you were like a like a girl or you were somebody who talked about
like wearing a dress getting in the ass. You're like, "Yeah,
a little bit." Yeah, that's what you thought. Okay. When Alec
Gunter was [__] on you saying you look like a fanboy
who was like always joking about getting [__] Yeah.
He he read you. Okay. He p Alec Gunter pondered the orb and he
saw and he knew.
things that sparked from this, including a lot of people bringing
up after they saw Sabrina Carpenter come out with this statement
is asking Taylor Swift where she's been at because over the last
few weeks, Taylor Swift has been under a lot of fire because
the White House did a similar thing with her. They used her song
behind, you know, one of these videos. But for whatever reason,
Taylor Swift just hasn't said anything and she didn't make any
like public statement like this. She didn't go behind the scenes
and like try to get it taken down or anything. It's just been
radio silent from her, which was just like super confusing for
a lot of people. >> Is that I guess I can kind of understand
why that would upset people. Maybe
I Oh man,
is that clearly Taylor Swift is MAGA? She's not MAGA. She's not
MAGA and she's explicitly like tried to do against, right? Sorry.
She's tried to explicitly do stuff against having that image.
She's like come out and canvas for Democrats and supported Democrat
candidates. She's tried to work against that image, but now she's
like dating Travis Kelce. And I wonder if just like the overlap
there is is like she she just doesn't want the the smoke on that
one. I don't know.
She's shifting to Trady though. Is she >> Because Taylor
Swift has released documentaries like talking about her support
for the Democratic party and in general making her politics like
very known. So, it was just like a weird omission here that for
some reason she was taken and a lot of people were attributing
this to recently like dating Travis Kelce and maybe a shift towards
being more Republican or MAG of some sorts. Now, I don't know
if I fully agree with that. I don't know if I've seen enough
like evidence to completely believe that.
god. But overall, it was just weird that she didn't say anything
about this. And with Sabrina coming out it >> well the
heavenly you say that but I think billionaires who are who build
their billions on public reputation I think
that's normally
something you are concerned about that's something you think
about care about right your reputation
and this would be a reputation thing to actually have somebody
monitoring this if not you then >> increase like the fire
of like people wondering where is she because this isn't just
a Sabrina thing or standards held to you pop stars, like plenty
of different other artists from all different genres have spoken
out about this. When the White House tries to do a similar thing
with their song, they get it taken down or make some kind of
like public statement saying they denounce this. Like Olivia
Rodrigo, Jack White specifically is suing them, I'm pretty sure,
for constantly using Seven Nation Army at Trump rallies. Metallica,
MGMT, even the Pokemon theme song where they posted a similar
video. See, this got to catch them all one was actually so deranged.
It's really funny. It's so deranged actually. >> Got to
catch them all while brutally chasing and arresting people. I'm
going to be honest. I don't get how this is supposed to be like
appealing at all. Like even for the everyday person or even everyday
Republican, even for the most extreme people who support what
uh frankly this is just gross. I mean, it is, but
I totally Sorry, he doesn't have a good idea of what Republicans
are like. No, I understand exactly how this is appealing to the
everyday Republican >> is doing and to the extremity of
the how they're doing it. How could you find this to even be
an appealing way to go about this in the first place? They have
like some Gen Z guy running this account trying to make it like
popular and memeify ICE to like casually get people to support
it more. That's the idea, I assume. but instead it just comes
across as this dystopian bizarre like cheering on a bunch of
people getting chased down, pushed down to the floor and being
handcuffed behind like their meme pop culture music to purposely
rage bait. It's just so embarrassing. Like this is how you want
your government to be ran. I just don't get it how at all. I
feel like every normal >> Yeah. Republicans think it's
awesome. They think it's >> just real question. Who's more
political knowledge lyrics or Diorio? Probably Nick. completely
down the MA pipeline is looking at this with such disturbed disgust.
But following this, the White House actually here's the question.
Okay, whose opinion is this? Is it
is it lyrics or is it his stylists?
Who really hates this? Is it lyrics or is it his stylist? I don't
know.
>> Here's a short and sweet message for Sabrina. So old.
just like, >> "Oh, his nails are painted, too." Oh, no.
Oh, no. No. [screaming]
It's not just a bit. It's not just a bit. It's not just a bit.
It's not just a bit. It's It's absolutely not just a >> Like
the biggest self-report for being
>> "Bro, I didn't notice it." Hold on.
>> Hold on. We've got We've got white and light very light
blue. Do we have a pink nail here?
I can't tell. We've got white, very light blue. Do we have the
pink? Bro, his background his lighting is like trans flight colored,
too.
Bro, there's so many e Why you Why are you hiding Easter eggs?
Lunar Box has painted nails. Painting your nails is just gay.
Yeah, I think Lerbox is probably like, let's be real, Lunbox
one of those poly dudes. I just I think it's all degeneracy
personally. Um and that's not like a super big judgment on him.
I mean if he can get multiple partners that's fine. I just think
it's all it's all like intermingled
that that I know that's an ignorant opinion. It's all intermingle
mingled. Ah I just don't I don't think like a lot of um moral
I don't feel a lot of moral condemnation for it but I think it's
something that detracts from happiness. Why do you care? Um because
I just say what I think. Why? Why do you think I care like significantly
to give an opinion on something? This entire stream is me talking
about stuff that I can never ever have an effect on. Care about
it? I don't know. I just talk about the stuff that's like popular
to talk about on stream and somebody literally asked
Why do you care? Why do you care? It actually doesn't hurt anybody.
Be it doesn't hurt anyone. Why does it Why do you care if it
doesn't hurt anybody? Uh I don't know. I just notice a correlation
and then give my opinion. I just Yeah, that's how the stream
works. Boom. like the biggest self-report for being like 50 plus.
What are these puns, man? Here's a short and sweet message for
Sabrina. We won't apologize for deporting dangerous criminal
illegal illegal mur and pedophiles from our country. Yeah. Is
that all the people? Is that all the I mean, it's just lying.
It's just lying through their teeth that it's been confirmed.
Okay. I don't know. Is lyrics really gonna start releasing politics
content on his channel?
My god. My god, man.
By the way, I don't I literally like don't hate loader box or
something. I'm just saying that like usually I just think it
doesn't lead to happiness in general. That's always been my thought
that there's been >> uh isn't it weird that he's anti-conservative
now? Well, that's why I said I don't know if it's his opinion
or his handlers cuz from what I remember he used to be like the
turkey tom Auggie kind of guy where he's just like yeah the gays
the transes all these people they [__] suck
the LGBTQ
alphabet rainbow people okay used to be lyrics's like calling
card and now he's all like excuse me that Pokemon music over
that ice video is very offensive that Pokemon video that Pokemon
music with the ice video that's horrible That's just terrible.
Now, I've always been like, "Oh, these people suck." But for
him, he was like on the side of performatively like cheering
these people on. Very goofy. Okay.
Very, very, very goofy. Okay. I've been told that there's not
a ton of other content in this. We can watch this whole >> It's
only five places that don't fall under those.
>> Anyone who would defend these sick monsters must be
stupid. Or is it slow?
>> Man, these puns have got to stop. Somebody somebody's
got to do something about this. Somebody's got to put an end
to this. This is this is like the worst part. But despite the
surface level like huge support for Sabrina here, there was actually
a huge amount of people who um did not like this comment from
her who quote tweeted with insane amount of likes things along
these lines. Do not ever involve my church in your music to benefit
your evil agenda.
150,000 likes, 13 million views. Man, this is the level of like
the culture war that we're at where people are so desperate for
an hypocrisy that they end up defending someone who is far more
disrespectful to your religion. >> Okay. Okay. Now,
now I see it. Okay. Now I see it. Now I'm hearing Yeah. Now I'm
hearing the voice. Now I'm hearing a voice.
Now I'm hearing a
>> like the culture war that we're at where people are
so desperate for an hypocrisy that they end up defending someone
who is far more disrespect.
>> Yeah. This dude dude dude dude dude hand gesturing is
the same as his hand gestures have always been.
But no the hand I'm sorry. The hands were always gay which is
maybe if you want to say that's how you knew he was going to
be like trans or something in the future. I think he's always
done the hands. Hands are a big feature of his content always
forever.
But I Dude, the voice change is cra the voice change happened
like in the same sentence. >> Full agenda. 150,000 likes,
13 million views. Man, this >> it's like all in this sentence.
He he goes from like kind of normal to and bassy to like he softens
through the sentence. This is the level of like the culture war
that we're at where people are so desperate for an hypocrisy
that they end up defending someone who is far more disrespectful
to your religion than Sabrina Carpenter could dream to be. Like
is the
>> point really that you're calling out a pop star for
recording a music video in a church when Trump on a daily basis
stands for far more immoral things that would go completely against
your religion? and disrespect the church. I mean, come on, man.
Like, this is what he's posting online. This is his own account.
This has got to be blasphemy of some kind of order. Like, he's
posing himself as a false idol posing as the pope in like this
AI generated slop. That's got to be against some kind of commandment.
You're calling out this, but you have no issue here. This is
a clip of the guy you're defending saying there's nothing he
can possibly do to get himself into heaven. That's how much of
an immoral person he's been in his >> I don't think there's
anything gonna get me in heaven. Okay. I really I think I think
I'm not maybe heaven bound. >> Come on. [laughter] The
jokes write themselves and I can't what? That's funny.
I'm sorry. That's very funny.
That's what takes like one of the very very very few funny Trump
moments and goes, "The jokes write themselves. What? Why do you
need more jokes?" Okay, dude. She She responds to the White House.
Somebody quotes quote tweets her with the Eiffel Tower photo.
I think unfortunately for me, this doesn't really seem to hit.
This is one of the things Sabrina Carpenter is just like proudly,
oh, she's like, "Yeah, I'm What's up?" That's I I don't know
how you insult her with this one. That's >> stress enough
that there were so many tweets like this with an insane amount
>> like This is This is not even the worst picture, dude.
That album cover she did, that was crazy. You guys remember that
al that
Sabrina
Carpenter
album cover? Her album cover was insane. Hold on. Do we have
the full thing here? I don't even have the full thing there,
dude. Her album cover, her album was called Man's Best Friend,
and it's just like her on her knees with her hair getting pulled
by a dude.
That's like her album cover.
That's like somehow she managed to make this insanely more suggestive
than uh than Oh, where did the tweet go?
No. How did I Oh, it's on the video. That's why. Than this. Infinitely
more suggestive. Jesus. Engagement. This quote tweet right here.
230K likes of Sabrina doing one of her Juno poses at her concert.
So, a a pop star being
>> a Juno pose. That's her. What is it? Okay, maybe I'm
Maybe I'm just not a zoomer, so I don't know. That's I I call
that an Eiffel Tower pose. Okay. I don't know. She getting like
deep. She getting Come on, man. What's it? The song is called
Juno. Okay.
Does Larry think that this was invented at the This is like,
by the way, when Lar selfinserts into this image, we all know
that he's Sabrina Carpenter, right?
Right. Like Lyric is thinking about this and he's like, "Yeah,
that's that's so me. That's so that's how he selfinserted this
picture." I'm telling you. >> Sabrina doing one of her
Juno poses at her concert. So pop star being and expressing herself.
This is who we're comparing to the president of the United States
to the government of one of the most powerful countries in the
world. Like can we have some perspective for a second? Even if
like Sabrina Carpenter was doing things that were immoral in
like your point of view, she's just a pop star. She's just a
random pop star versus the most one of the most powerful people
in the world who you're defending by proxy with this.
Wait, what? Who you're defending by proxy? Wait, what?
Okay. I don't know. I [sighs] It's not a comparison of their
actions. It's not defending by proxy. It's defending directly.
They're saying you're a stupid for for like DMCA my my Trump
emperor's song. You DMCA
my emp my my God Emperor's song. You you stupid. What do you
mean by proxy? They're like directly saying you with Donald Trump
you [__]
What do you mean by proxy? >> Who does worse things? Yeah.
And this tweet right here just shows where they're coming from
to be. >> Unless she's talking about def unless he's talking
about defending Taylor Swift by proxy
but there it's not by proxy. He's literally This video is evil
and disgusting. Do not ever involve me or my music to benefit
your inhumane agenda.
This is like direct He's just directly They're all directly saying
stupid.
You stupid [__] Honest. Don't blasphemy my faith,
ugly [__] These are the Christians. These are the
faithfilled people. It's like, okay, [laughter] what is going
on here, man? What is this? What is this? How is this? What?
his voice softened by another level again. Faith ugly. What?
>> These are the Christians. These are the faithfilled
people. It's like >> these are the Christians. These are
the faithfilled people. >> Like, okay, [laughter] what
is going on here, man? What? >> Dude, he's he's trying
not He laughed. He managed to retain his normal laugh there,
but he really wanted to go like a borderline Hassan laugh. Okay.
>> Is this what is this? How is this what Jesus would?
>> Blink's eyes furiously. Blinks eyes >> would do.
Is this what he would do as well? the guy who had >> What
is going on here? What is You're defending Donald Trump? Oh my
god. You're defending Donald Trump. Blink blink blink blink blink.
>> Passion for everyone. Even if they what you think she's
doing is wrong. Sit down with prostitutes would have dinner with
taxpayers. Are you following it? Dude, the whole uh there's is
there anything worse
that exists than somebody who like clearly doesn't believe in
God at all? Trying to use like a religious um like a a religious
hypocrisy against you. I don't believe in this at all, but you
know, I heard that your Jesus guy was like he like liked wh heard
that your Jesus guy was really into [__] Shouldn't
you just love all no matter what? Shouldn't you just love every
amount of degeneracy no matter what? cuz Jesus like hung out
with prostitutes. Shouldn't you like isn't that a part of your
faith or something? You don't know about their faith. What the
are you talking about? Shut the up. >> In his footsteps
right here. >> I And I say that as somebody who's not religious.
I'm just like, dude, why? I don't Why would they care about your
opinion?
You clearly don't care to inform yourself. Shut the up >> with
uh you know, this kind of behavior. But yeah, going back to the
Taylor Swift thing for a quick minute though, there's also this
huge tweet saying forever in the history book. >> According
to the New Testament, yeah, though, well, I don't think the New
Testament says all whoring is based no matter what. I don't think
that's what it says. I think it says Jesus didn't judge people
who were willing to turn towards the light, right? Like you can
get absolution from from any uh what would you call like sinful
acts, but it's not like, oh, it's totally fine to just be a prostitute
and keep sucking dick and never ever try to get married or change
your life. That's not That's not the point. Which is what these
people always do. Actually, isn't it super based to be a No,
it's superb based to forgive people no matter what their transgressions
are. That's what it's superb to do. Is Sabrina Carpenter turning
towards the light? Is she going to live a a less sinful life
now or what is she going to do? I
>> artists that have condemned Donald Trump for using their
music in rallies and political campaigns. Sabrina, >> yeah,
I between the stars, you absolutely are right, but this isn't
holding somebody to be consistent. It's not saying they're be
they need to be consistent. So Sabrina Carpenter has shown no
proclivity to want to go and be like a more virtuous person at
all. Yeah. Okay. Well, okay. You just I I can tell exactly who
you are, right? You have Christian parents who are very annoying
to you and you're like, "Oh, actually, it's really based to hold
my Christian parents to their beliefs and you didn't listen.
Didn't listen to what I was saying." >> Carpenter, Olivia
Rodrigo. >> So now I've judged you. You've been
>> Beyonce Rihanna. >> Okay. Sorry. Are you from
Are you from England? Yeah, your parents definitely aren't Christian.
That's my bad. >> Dallas, Lean Dion, Nickelback, Aerosmith,
Jack White, Aba, Bill Collins, Free, the list goes on. You know what
I mean? >> And then artists that have Yes, >> I'm
going to go back to the first guest and say that that was all
correct. >> Openly opposed the Trump administration for
using their music. Taylor Swift, and this is like a huge sentiment
that's been brewing as well. This isn't just like a small thing.
Like a lot of people are talking about this and very confused
on Taylor's choice here. And yeah, I just don't get it. if she
hasn't caught wind of it somehow or what, but it's like it is
a very important thing. It's not a small thing to like be poking
some uh this is by the way all this is this is really easy to
understand. Okay, it's just Taylor's Republicans wear Nikes 2
moment. Okay,
you definitely got like 80 people in her org structure who are
all on her like Republican outreach campaign trying to get all
of these Republican like women and girls to buy her music, right?
Right. She got married to an NFL player. She's going to live
the like the best American life she can. Yeah. This is all like
marketing stuff. This is all to make more money and be the the
biggest star, the biggest institution that exists in all of like
popular
I think I think that's all this is. And that's why she wouldn't
get the music DMCA cuz she's not going to leave it alone. No,
because this is like an endorsement for Republicans. No, it's
a it's not an endorsement for Republicans. Unless you think Michael
Jordan going actually Republicans wear Nikes, too. Was an endorsement
for Republicans. Dung Devil donated $3. You're a gay prostitute,
BT. >> Thank you, Dung Devil, for the $3. Only $3 to send
something similar, guys.
I don't I don't understand in what way I could possibly be like
that, but thank you for the three bucks. someone at for it's
a very important thing and especially someone who's openly as
political as Taylor Swift has been in the past to like stand
on those beliefs and if someone is actively using your work like
the government of the United States is using your work does this
mean like selling fee pics on the internet it means they sold
their soul to money but that's obvious
>> yeah this like selling fee pics >> to promote
something like this to further try to push their agenda on the
youth online you should be standing,
not only legally getting it taken down, but saying that this
is wrong and you shouldn't be doing this. I feel like if you're
a political person who believes in that, that's like what you
should be doing. But yeah, I don't know. So hopefully she says
something.
>> This is
maybe fine. I think really all it tells you is when she did the
whole, "Oh, I'm a Democrat actually." I think that was because
I I genuinely feel like she probably doesn't make her own like
public statements. she almost certainly has like a PR team who
did a focus group and was like actually Democrats pull really
well right now and now they're like well it's pretty close and
family like traditional values pull really well and so don't
like don't DMCA Donald Trump because that's going to really undo
that message Taylor Swift we're talking about Taylor Swift sorry
not Sabrina Carpenter Sabrina Carpenter is not like that Sabrina
Carpenter DMCA the song we're talking about the comparison between
them where where Taylor Swift has not DMCA any of the music and
her is kind of people are like I don't know about you >> because
so far it's just really weird. But that's going to be the case
right here for this video. Thank you all so much for watching.
I really appreciate it. There's many more videos coming soon.
Sorry for the inactivity lately, but believe me, you know, especially
going into 2026. I appreciate everybody supporting the channel
and everything. And there's going to be even more videos, more
streams, and every I'm really looking forward to it. So, thank
you everybody for continued watching. If you like the video,
like, subscribe if you want to see more videos exactly like this.
Thank you for all the Patreon viewers who help out the channel.
If you want to shout out the end of these videos, you could join
right here. And for tiers two and three, if you want to
Okay. Wow. All right. Now.